Right,
we're going to go live in five,
four,
three,
two.
So tell me about your feminist.
I got it here.
Um,
girl logic.
It was the difference between,
oh,
the genius and the absurdity.
What's the difference between girl logic
and boy logic or do you know?
Because I don't know,
I can't tell you exactly the way men
think because I think if I did that it'd
be like slow your roll.
The book is about me sort of noticing
that women are always called crazy
psycho psychopaths psycho bitch,
you know,
like oh she's insane.
We always write off women as crazy and
women are expected to be so many things
to so many people at once and if these
expectations that sort of we have to
take into account all of this and we try
to be so many things at once and we have
to take in so much stimuli to process
all this.
So our logic is sort of,
it's sort of this like circumlocutions
way of thinking that seems insane.
Slow that word down.
What was that circle like?
You know,
like going around in circles.
I was at work was say it again,
circle the computer,
this big bird or whatever like that.
I've never heard that before.
So it's like,
um,
I'd never heard of the mad cow thing.
You were telling me that earlier and I
was like,
oh my God,
are we on?
I was,
as you were talking about,
I was like,
please don't make me look stupid.
I don't know about El Kevin Crazy
brains,
but I just the base,
the boiler plate example is,
you know,
you say to a girl what do you want to
eat?
Right.
And that's always an argument.
It's like this common trope,
like my wife couldn't ever figure it
out,
but it has less to do with women wanting
to be difficult and more pressure on
just that one decision.
If I say pizza,
am I doing a diet?
Do I have to be in a bathing suit later?
Did I go to the gym already?
Am I expected to be thin in this
society?
And we take all of this into account for
every micro decision.
And it's all about processing how we
don't let everyone,
including ourselves down and all the
thought that goes into it.
Well No,
this is used specifically,
like obviously you're not speaking for
all women,
but I actually got the title,
I got the rights to it,
I pulled 10 women.
They were like,
it's cool.
So I need is honoring the fact that we
get painted with these broad brush
strokes and there's so many and there's
just so much that goes into the littlest
things because we have to take into
account how other people feel.
So it's easy to say,
oh,
just be yourself,
but when you're a woman,
other people's perceptions of you can
have detrimental effects on your future,
on your safety,
on your health.
She seemed slutty so she deserved it.
She seems like a bitch.
I don't want to give her a chance,
you know?
So our perception versus the way that we
are,
we're,
we're constantly wrestling with these
two sort of realities.
Yeah.
I,
I've often wondered like if you could
like,
I believe that one day they're going to
be able to,
you know,
today we have transgender people,
right?
We have people who decide to have
operations decided to take hormones,
but I think one day they're going to be
able to literally a person into a woman
with a shot.
Yeah.
Well,
not with some sort of treatment.
I just feel like it sounds crazy to say
today people say,
no,
you can't change your chromosomes.
Well today you can't change your
chromosomes,
but 200 years ago the idea of sending a
video to someone in Australia,
it'd be ridiculous.
Right?
So like what we've been able to do just
over a short period of time,
relatively is pretty staggering.
And if you look at like what they're
doing with Crispr,
do you know what Crispr is?
It's gene editing tools that they keep
evolving there.
They've gotten them to the point where
they're starting to work on human
embryos,
non-viable human embryos in there.
They're changing the expression of
certain genes has changed.
Genes got stopping genes for certain
diseases and there's.
Yeah,
I don't like this chair.
I knew it was expensive.
It can drop if you want to make it
lower.
Close to my heart.
Okay.
Hm.
Interesting.
Um,
but the idea is that they're going to be
able to like make designer people.
Sure.
Right.
So this,
this is less,
this is,
you know,
you're a woman obviously with by
genetics and your Genitalia,
but this book is all about the
experiences and this is more societal
based.
This is less about what you're born as.
That was,
that's what I was going to say.
I was like I was saying if,
if you could like I,
I've wondered if that was a possibility
they could reverse it.
What I want to be a woman for like a
week.
Yeah,
for a week,
but let me see it just to see,
just to play with them.
Just stick stuff up there.
But I think that like we don't,
we don't know about the,
the closest you come to understanding a
man or a woman if you're a man or if
you're the opposite.
Sex I think is living with one or having
one or having one.
Yeah,
that's a big one for me was having
daughters and just seeing how they just
interact.
Sure.
From the time they're one until you
know,
they're older.
It's some of its biology.
Yeah.
You know,
this whole,
you know,
when you,
and I've talked about or know of someone
else,
but still the sort of um,
what women excluding other women.
So this goes back to when we were
hunters and gatherers.
If you didn't want someone to live,
you'd turn your back on them and you
wouldn't share information and then you
and your offspring will die.
Right?
So some you see this,
a little girls like they're mean,
they're mean to each other and as you
get older,
you know,
you're taking in all of this stimuli
from society,
all the messages and we have to process
these things and then eventually you get
old enough,
you're like,
fuck it,
I'm going to do it my own way.
But there's still expectations place.
And a lot of them are conflicting like
polar opposites.
Like you have to be sexy but also
demure,
outgoing,
but don't be too pushy and too pushy or
outgoing.
They're relative depending on who's in
your path,
so,
and women have to take these things into
account because we got to do everything
second.
We didn't create professional sports or
corporations.
We're late to the game for everything.
So it's a man's world and you do have to
take into account those rules and it
sucks,
but these are all the things that we
have to factor in when we're making
decisions.
Then there's always going to be a
certain amount of resentment if someone
tries to do it a woman's way rather than
a man's what?
You need a tissue?
Never going to stop running.
But uh,
you,
uh,
you have allergies.
I don't know.
My nose just always runs a little bit
too much.
I hate.
I hate when people do so much.
He knows it's so little.
I don't know how you get coke up there.
You have coke rocks that we get stuck in
your nose holes.
They're still stuck up there.
Keep it like I've wondered like I don't
work right.
I don't have a job,
a real job and I haven't had one in a
long,
long time.
So the idea of like having a boss is
alien to me and had a female boss is
even more annoying to me.
Sure.
So I was,
I'm talking to someone who has a woman
boss and um,
we,
we were saying that there's an
interesting thing that happens where a
woman can do the exact same thing and
she's a bitch.
Whereas if the guy does it,
he's stern,
he's a hard ass or no,
it's a,
it's all this,
you know,
as women age,
their gross and men are austere or the
regal intersects,
you know.
And those are kind of basic examples,
Um,
and I think we're moving away from that.
It's more nuanced things I like,
you really can't identify with workplace
issues.
I talked to some friends of mine,
they're like,
I hate that I have to dumb things down
or people express and in my domain,
like I worked very hard to be the one in
charge and men don't speak to me that
way because they're opening for me.
Right,
right,
right.
There's just,
I don't have that hierarchy.
So they're the manager of the club or
you got to pay me anyway.
So,
um,
but it doesn't mean that I don't have a
sort of sympathy for that and that I
don't understand what it feels like to
be discounted.
So as long as time you had a job job,
job,
job was probably 2004,
five,
six relatively recently,
12 years,
15 years ago.
And I wasn't mentally present that much
for it.
It was kind of relaxed,
you know,
but,
and it wasn't like I wasn't trying to
get ahead at that job.
It was 2006.
So 11 years ago.
That's like a base of maybe seven years
ago,
maybe,
maybe 2007.
So 10 years ago,
11 or whatever it is that you're like a
different human.
Right.
You're so like,
do you remember it very well?
Like what was the job?
I was the last job I had,
I was an assistant in the marketing
department of a large company that dealt
with like Black Jack.
It was like a black Jack.
It was like a new kind of interesting
and so.
But this Nice Jewish guy hired me and I
was just there to answer the phone if
anyone ever called,
make some press kits like it was monkey
work and you were obviously doing
standup.
I was doing standup at night and I would
spend the days sort of like soliciting
people if I could get a spot on their
show,
making flyers,
like I just use it as my own office and
I didn't have also the environment like
I could wear pajamas to work.
Like no one ever came to.
Our office was barely,
barely a regular job.
Yeah,
there's definitely.
I wasn't like in the workforce now
happening
regular jobs.
There's obviously a huge problem with
the dynamic that men and women have in
regular jobs,
but there's a problem with men and men
in regular jobs like pee.
I don't think that it's normal for
people to be working on top of each
other doing something they don't want to
do for long stretches of time.
I think it's very difficult to be
yourself.
You have all these restrictions on your
language and the way you're allowed to
communicate with each other and then
you're obviously doing something all day
that you would rather not be doing.
So I have two thoughts on that.
One.
It's interesting because we have this
corporate structure which is really
designed to minimize suing and to
minimize issues,
but since humans aren't meant to be put
in these boxes,
I think it perhaps creates more problems
were too confined,
but it's interesting.
I opened a lot of my snaps on snapchat
and you'll always get ones that are
like,
ugh,
for 49 can for the state of database
over hate work,
don't want to go into work.
It's all about hating your job,
which I don't understand because I.
I love my job and I worked very hard to
have a job that I enjoy,
but I don't know if everybody I talk in
my book about,
you know,
your passion and finding it and whenever
you can find it.
Not everybody's meant for greatness.
Not everybody's meant to be happy and
some people are dumb and I know this
sounds terrible.
Like I'm designing some master plan,
but some people need to just go and do
the shitty job.
You're not contributing.
Not everybody is meant like this is like
some Hitler Eugenic Shit.
Make my fucking phone be quiet because
if you think about the majority of
people you talked to,
like some people are not bright and no,
you don't have the mental wherewithal to
carve out your own happiness.
So
that's a genetic thing.
I'd always had an environmental thing.
I think it's a religious thing.
No,
I don't know.
It just takes all kinds.
Right?
It does take all,
but I will always wonder like is it what
they've experienced in their life?
Is it the family environment that they
grew up in?
Is it just straight raw genetics?
Some people are just dumb.
I don't know if it's nature versus
nurture.
Fix that.
Well,
I will tell you this.
I do think it's more nurture than
anything because I go and I read to kids
at at this elementary school and they're
all Latino.
They all speak Spanish.
There's not a blonde kid in the group
and I think it's very easy to write off
minorities,
you know,
they don't speak English as their
parents don't speak English,
whatever and the kids are so fucking
smart and like they're like four years
old and they're reading and they're
guessing things and they speak two
languages and you get chills because
you're like,
I don't know if you're going to have the
opportunities I had and that kills me
because I can see that you're smart and
you want to like take one which is
illegal and like put them in a good
school.
But I mean that's just the way of the
world as opposed
diet.
I think diet is a huge part of it is a
huge part in the way a child's mind and
body develop.
I was,
I read this article,
I want to say it was in the Atlantic,
but it was about sort of the language
surrounding and running clean
eating and how that term shames people
who are poor because you're suggesting
that their food is dirty,
which it is to an extent,
but it how clean eating is just for rich
people.
That's a silly way of describing it.
No,
it's not.
That's not what it means.
It means there's a lack of preservatives
and bullshit,
but that's all in and twinkies are
affordable and they're filled with
garbage.
Yeah,
but let us is affordable too.
I mean it's not expensive to eat queen.
No.
In terms of.
I mean it's expensive.
You want to go to whole foods,
but you have to define.
I mean clean to everyone is different.
Right.
It's a weird term and is just one
interesting.
It was just one take on it.
I don't know if I totally agree with it,
but like I did the.
I started doing the Ketogenic Diet and
my father isn't doing it,
but he takes these exogenous Kita Jens,
I guess,
and he's like,
my mind is sharp.
I'm focused and I think there was a bit
of a power of suggestion,
but I definitely don't have an energy
dip and I feel like my body's burning
clean fields.
Very legit.
I mean there's.
There's a lot of science behind it.
There's a podcast that I did pretty
recently with a guy named Dom
D'agostino,
who's a scientist and does a lot of
clinical research on kidogenic diet and
he.
He can give you like real raw hard data,
but there's A.
There's a big issue with your body
burning off carbohydrates,
especially in particularly refined
carbohydrates and then spikes of insulin
and then the dips.
You just feel terrible and you need a
nap in the middle of the day.
I've been operating that way for so
long.
I'm not saying I'm enlightened now and
this will be it forever,
but I was like,
yeah,
you just take a nap.
President takes a nap.
People,
most of Europe takes an APP.
You take a nap and I started doing this
and I was just on this press tour and I
went into it and this is sometimes just
knowing that it changes possible is
almost more important than the outcome.
I went onto this thing in New York and
every time you do press it's like you're
up at 6:00
AM,
you're done at 7:00
PM and it's a gauntlet and I always feel
disgusting and tired and bloated and
this time I was like,
I'm just going to.
I'm going to do the ketogenic diet
throughout,
and I never needed a nap.
I didn't feel like I outgrew my clothes.
Like I felt like a human and I felt
pretty,
which is such a weird thing,
but like there's nothing worse than
being bloated as a girl and it's got to
be the Diet because you're burning clean
fuel and there's no dips and if you
think about every time you reach for a
snack,
which is so easy or a piece of candy and
a Green Room,
you're doing that to your body that the
spikes and that's exhausting and that's
why you're napping at 4:00
everyday.
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not good for you and we're not
designed to consume food like that.
I'm just not all these refined
carbohydrates.
It's a massive part of the modern diet.
It's just,
it's really recent.
Last few hundred years.
Humans have had it in the last hundred
years,
has changed pretty radically.
I um,
I went to this thing called the summit,
which is Kinda like a giant Ted talk and
I did some stand up there and just end
up at it.
I just went.
How many people did stand up there?
It just meat Bengali.
You've invited me.
And so I went,
um,
what has been doing there?
He did some stand up before and uh,
so I did it and then after,
you know,
it fosters this environment
of sort of open mindedness and just talk
and you can just talk to people.
And I,
it was the first week of the Diet,
so I had the Keto flu and I had to leave
the comedy store one night I had a
second show and I was talking to Steve
Simone about cheese and I almost threw
up and I was like,
I have to go home because my own diet
was making me so nauseous because that's
part of it.
You get sick at the beginning I never
got the,
I just got tired to the point where it
was fucking with my workouts so my
workouts folds flat.
But exoticness ketones are the way to
kill that.
So I was taking those two.
But it's also,
you're kinda like you're reading stuff
and you're kind of sussing out what
works for you and trying to find the
right balance.
Anyways.
I was not feeling well,
but I was talking to everyone about this
diet.
I was like,
this could not be more La.
I'm like,
hi,
I'm Eliza.
I'm on a diet.
Check it out.
Like on the Keto Diet,
the Keto Diet,
that's big La.
And it's also like an intense thing,
like you're changing everything.
So I.
and so when you say you have a diet,
people want to tell you what's wrong
with it.
And I was like,
my favorite part of a diet is people
telling me how wrong I am for spending
all this money and doing this and this
one guy came up and he's like,
I'm a Vegan.
And I was like,
okay.
And he starts explaining why he's
basically a better person.
And I was like,
but your shoes are leather so fuck you.
okay.
He's like,
you're impacting the world in a negative
way.
I'm like,
okay,
but do you recycle?
And like,
no,
like we all do what we can.
And you're not a better person just
because you happen to eat only herbs and
maybe you don't drive a prius.
Like who knows where you're making your
shitty.
The desire to project that on people.
Absolutely.
I was like this.
I don't say I'm not telling anyone to do
it.
I was just saying what I'm doing.
I'm going to mean you're not saying
you're a better person,
but him saying he's a better person for
that or he didn't say he was acting
like.
You know what I'm saying?
It's one of the reasons why people do
those.
This moral high ground that they take.
That being said,
that being said,
when I see people eating garbage,
I do feel superior.
I'm not hungry.
Well,
you realize they're doing something bad
or their body.
It's way I feel when I see someone
smoking cigarettes,
man,
but I'm not going to say something to
you.
You should walk up to them and start
coughing.
Okay.
Can I tell you,
I was at starbucks the other day and I
just was running in to grab an espresso
shot because I have one every time I
work out and I go in and there's a girl
there and were comic.
So a big part of our job is sort of
scanning people,
identifying what they are,
making assumptions because we're usually
right.
So this girl in front of me and she's
standing there holding a snack because
usually we're usually right.
That's why we're successful and she's
holding her snacks and,
and I can see that she's Kinda weighing
her options and I see you're putting out
and I see her grab a banana.
So to me,
for the most part when women do that,
it is about a dietary thing.
You're trying to lose weight.
She looked like she was maybe going to
the gym.
I don't know.
So just trying to be a good girl to
another girl.
I just,
because I thought she was making like a
sugar based decision.
I go bananas full of sugar just because
I didn't know that I did it because
someone told that to me because you
always think of bananas healthy.
You put it in a smoothie shake.
I didn't know so much sugar so I just
said it just as a like,
hey girlfriend,
I didn't know this.
And so she and,
and Oh God,
what did she say?
She looked at me and she said something
and she was.
And then the,
the,
the Barista like gotta tune.
She goes,
fruit has a lot of sugar.
I go,
well,
blueberries have a load by simic index
and just bananas have more.
I just didn't know that was it.
I was just trying to be cool.
I leave.
I'm walking through the courtyard and I
hear this,
excuse me,
and it's the girl from inside and she
goes,
did you know dying?
Your hair causes cancer.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
That was it in the place.
I go to the banana sugar.
She goes,
but it has potassium,
and I go,
well,
we don't really know what potassium does
doing.
I mean,
we know what's in bananas.
Like I was just trying to be funny and I
leave and she comes across when she
goes,
do you know the dying to hear it causes
cancer?
And Joe,
I thought she was fucking with me.
And I go,
yeah,
but there's a lot of potassium and hair
dye.
And she goes,
you really shouldn't tell people what
they should and shouldn't eat.
You don't know what I'm going through.
And I was like,
I do now.
Crazy.
Oh crazy.
That is crazy.
It's crazy.
Oh,
for sure.
Oh yeah.
Are fucking.
If you're gonna like you're gonna attack
on me in a courtyard and tell me to go
fuck myself because I just said bananas.
Have she got like so offended?
Well you are slim and maybe she was not.
She was fine.
Looking fine.
Maybe she has a body image thing who
doesn't?
My point is if you can't suss out,
but I was just making tommy super
comfortable as body.
I'm pretty comfortable with my.
Alright.
But the point is I get and I asked
everyone,
I was like,
was I wrong?
And sometimes you just catch someone.
Like I've always described it this way,
like most people all day long,
if you're lucky,
people are at like a two or a three out
of 10 on the outrage scale.
But you might run into someone who's at
a nine.
They just,
they might've just got dumped their car.
My be getting repossessed.
They might've just got fired.
They might just got yelled at by their
mom.
There might be like a whole series of
things and behind her with the fucking
banana,
banana sugar,
just bitch.
If you're listening,
which I doubt it because you don't seem
like the kind of person that wants to be
enlightened,
but if you're listening,
this is not a good apology.
Knows about cancer and hair dye and
that's what she wanted to tell you.
Well,
I'm not going to not be blond.
I'm not gonna.
Walk around with like roots just because
it causes cancer.
Maybe.
I'm sorry if I offended you.
I'm sorry.
Banana Lady.
Banana ladies.
Do you need a hug?
Um,
does,
does hair dye actually caused cancer?
I've never read that.
Doesn't like,
doesn't involve.
Well,
living in a city causes cancer for sure.
Oh my God.
It's got a big time for you.
They say they say they say that living
near a highway I give you live within a
certain distance of a highway.
Can Shave 10 years off your life.
I believe that not just from small,
but anxiety.
I believe twitter is slowly killing us
to really do twitter and I have a foil
helmet to prove it.
I the amount of anxiety it causes.
I think the bad far outweighs the good.
Do you,
do you like read comments and talk back
to people and have conversation now and
I had a conversation at the improv where
you were frantic.
That sounds like a year ago you were
getting into it with someone.
God dammit,
I wish I could remember what it was
about,
but you are fucking pissed and you were
frantic and you had been going at it
with all these people and they were
pissed at you.
Do you remember
the make America great again?
Thing that I went through,
which was horrible,
but I could have been something about
racism.
Sounds like my running with Hashtag
Maga.
Maybe that's what it was,
but we were in the front of the Improv
and you were so fucking frantic and
angry and frustrated and I said it was
just don't read that stuff.
Just don't.
Don't,
don't engage.
Like you wouldn't engage with those
people in real life.
You're like,
you're right,
but I have to fucking tell them because
they say this.
I can genuinely tell you this.
I gave it up.
I had like my own thing.
I did this interview and some girls got
like butthurt over something and it was
then that I was just like,
you know what,
I'm done.
I'm done reading all of this,
so I'll skim it once in a while for like
a,
like a retweet about something or if
someone's posting something,
but I,
if you look at my tweets,
they're all just sort of self
generating.
There's Vr,
there's no responses anymore.
I've just decided like you're following
me for a reason.
So what I say is the,
is what I'm saying and I don't need to
backtrack and that's just the stance
that I've taken because it really is
like screaming into a pillow.
That's all it is.
Like with all and by the way,
but don't you find interesting?
Do you find interesting things and then
tweet them out to people like,
hey,
look at this cool article I just read.
I will retweet people's things if I
think someone's brilliant.
There's this girl just to whack who I
can't stop talking about,
uh,
who has single handedly upending the
trump administration.
Like her tweets are so brilliant.
Just dweck.
How do you think it's dw?
E,
C,
k?
I think I phone.
She's just so good and I just believe in
if something's good,
perpetuating it and putting it out
there.
So I retweet hers.
If somebody says something funny,
I retweet it,
but.
And,
but I don't answer people.
Dew,
W e,
c,
k dot just get ready for a boost.
Yeah,
they're just hot fire.
But she does a good job.
So I like to retweet it.
The dweck is her,
her name,
she was on a show I did last night.
I did a women only invite show and she
did a women only.
Could I go if I wore drag?
No,
I'm not allowed to know because I'd be
like,
what if I identify as a woman?
So people ask that and I was just like,
you can come,
but no one did that.
Oh,
you can come if you identify as a trans
woman.
I'm not going to be the one to tell you.
You just figured it out like five
minutes before the show here.
Here's why you can't because it's about
a lifetime as a woman.
So if you were always a man,
you probably just aren't going through
the same things that a woman who's a
woman was born a woman,
but you can come.
I'm not going to be the one to say no.
Um,
what's your stance on Trans racialism?
It's okay.
Oh,
sorry.
No,
no,
I didn't get the with the like,
uh,
the Rachel dolezal person.
I don't think it works.
You can't be another race.
Well,
how can you be a woman then?
How can a man be a woman?
What if you really aren't hockey?
If a man feels like he's a woman,
why is that different than a man feeling
like he's like.
There was one I tweeted yesterday,
a guy who believes he's Filipino,
he was born.
I think he's transgender as well.
He's got both things going on.
You know,
I think it's people that just don't like
who they are and they feel like a
radical shift.
There is transracial man born white says
he feels Filipino.
And by the way,
that makes it into USA Today.
Is he a nurse news?
Maybe that's why he feels that scrubs.
It's like tie dye,
looks like scrubs a.
This is where he has purple highlights
in his hair or can I just say that?
It seems to be the issue is when white
wants to be another color,
everybody has been forced to sort of
take on white characteristics.
Black girls flattened their hair,
nose jobs.
Do you know about Sammy Sosa?
Yeah.
And getting lighter.
Do you know what he looks like now?
Yes,
I do.
Because he looks like you.
He looks just like 10.
He knows he doesn't have a tiny nose,
but he has like literally your color
skin.
So my best friend,
her wife is Dominican and she posted a
picture of it and she was like,
this is not a joke.
It's so sad that he feels that he has to
do this.
Holy Shit.
Just look at that.
He's a fat white concept.
The Gerber baby,
I mean I guess he got it off the
steroids and that's when his body sort
of started getting fucked up and it
doesn't work out anymore.
So he's big now.
But the white is outraged when you try
to be white.
I think people of color get angry when
it goes the other way.
Right?
Because they're like,
you don't get to just take on our look
as a costume.
That I think that's the social issue.
Yeah.
Not for sure.
But that's,
that's.
I guess that's my only answer.
Right?
But what if that's what you really feel
like you would be happy?
I didn't do it to a privately,
privately where,
uh,
a Dominican Day parade costume under
your overcoat.
We can get away with some of it.
Right?
Like affectations,
like you can get away with like if
you're a rapper you could sort of talk
or MC search.
I think it's like teetering on that
line.
Who's MC search?
You don't remember the third base.
He used to have a,
a,
a TV show and it was horrible.
It was a talk show,
but he was going to keep it real.
And it was.
Yeah.
It was so bad that opie and anthony used
to play clips from MC search show.
Yes.
That's him.
Is He Jewish?
Because we do this.
We love hip hop.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's from back in the day.
I was a big fan of third base.
I love them as a,
as a band,
but his show,
well,
you know what his show,
here's the difference between his show
and what his show could be.
He,
uh,
that's awful,
but he thinks he's being choked out by
like he was all.
He was also wearing makeup and he was
also being,
I'm sure produced.
You got to be yourself and you can't be
yourself.
If you're on a fucking network,
you just can't.
They're not going to let you,
they're going to force you some box.
They're gonna,
they're gonna.
Figure out a way to sell you like,
this is what you're going to be.
You're going to be the.
This guy did a pilot for look at them.
Hey search,
I think it was oxygen.
And they were like,
we need you to say things like,
keep it 100.
Ooh,
can you say that for me?
Keep it 100.
I like it.
Keep it $100.
Nobody says that you stupid.
Fuck.
There was a while ago,
but this is how dumb they are.
People write that.
They don't fucking say it.
No one says,
keep it 100.
You dumb cunt.
Who are you?
But it's always that.
I always watched TV.
Advertising is always one step removed
from what's cool now because by the time
they push it through corporate too late,
it's like,
guess what?
No one's saying it anymore.
Right.
Remember was up.
Remember that one guy that had that
great video where it was like him
calling his friends was friends.
Like was.
It was a hilarious.
That was like the nineties,
right?
Here's another one that bothers me when
people say I almost threw up in my
mouth.
Oh,
you didn't invent it.
Stop using it in commercials.
Yeah.
That's not good.
Bad.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of those that they use.
They go,
Ooh,
this will connect with the kids will be
able to sell more things.
Well,
the worst is when like exact SCO.
We want it.
We want to make a viral video.
I'm like,
you can't,
it becomes viral.
It goes viral,
will make a viral video.
And then what was the other one?
Um,
when people.
It's bingeable.
When I was on free form,
we want bingeable.
We want everyone to binge.
I'm like,
you don't decide that you're going to
binge it just because you put all your
content out there.
You binged things because you decide
bingeable taught.
It's now it's fresh.
Oh God.
How can you be in that industry and keep
it real?
That's what I want to know.
Can You keep it real?
Can You keep it 100.
Look at that lady.
Oh,
what is she doing?
Is She doing the Dab?
Dab It on him.
Are you sure she's dabbing or she just
doing Tai Chi in the park?
Ah,
definitely.
Says it on her shirt,
on a shirt that she doesn't know she's
wearing.
She didn't realize that she can't read
the no 150,000
years old later,
just keep pounding.
Have.
Ooh.
We think it's so funny when old people
talk as if they were ever young and
fucking like as if they've never had
sex.
Right?
Like that lady probably at one point in
time was a connoisseur when she's out
there in the park,
not knowing what the fuck she's wearing.
Dinosaur in the park.
That's probably the best place probably
to be sampling Dick.
Probably hard to get a good one though
when you're at that age.
Probably real tough because it's all
about enthusiasm.
I feel like dudes are pretty down with
old ladies.
Like old dudes.
You.
Oh yeah.
Well that's an issue.
I'm a friend of mine go on.
One of his buddies worked at a old folks
home and said that one of the big issues
was these old guys would get Viagra.
Yeah.
And these old ladies,
they didn't give a fuck and a lot of
them are on antidepressants,
so they're like,
wow,
Allah who gives a shit.
Like they're on Xanax and getting stds.
That will.
I don't know if it was that.
That's something that I heard about,
like it's rampant because that's
happening.
That's probably really bad.
You're old,
right?
Like your body doesn't heal so good.
No.
[inaudible] 98.
Herpes is like an attack on your immune
system.
There it goes.
The new erotic frontier,
sex in nursing homes.
Until recently,
nursing homes frowned on sex.
Now increasingly they smile.
Oh,
well that makes sense.
Why?
Why shouldn't we have fun?
Look at this,
when Aubrey Davidson age,
85 minutes,
special guy at the Hebrew home in
Riverdale in the Bronx,
New York,
they did more than sit next to each
other in the dining room.
Then he invited her to his room.
They hung a do not disturb sign on the
door and at breakfast the next morning,
they both supported broad smiles,
terrible writing,
but also calling it.
What are the top say the you see the new
erotic frontier.
You're like,
oh,
and it's like sex and nursing homes.
You're like,
oh,
there goes the boner.
Well,
it sounded so hot.
Yeah,
that's not.
It's not exciting for me,
but there's a whole category on Youporn
so old people.
They do.
Some people do like watching old people.
Fuck.
You know what I watched the other day?
I'm not proud of it,
but I will admit it to you.
I watched an old thing,
my special.
I watched an old porn stars still at it.
I don't care what he provides.
Exercise and at the time of life when
many elderly feel cold sleeping as a
payer provides warmth.
Oh,
that's cute.
Look at this though,
like killed back to the relationships,
make people happier and that happiness
reduces stress and irritability and
improves mood,
appetite,
sleep,
sociability and immune function.
So to plants.
Read that first day.
Oh,
how dare you read the first sentence
says the Hebrew home.
That first one at the bottom of the
Hebrew home does more than tolerate
resident nookie.
The faculty hope.
Probably someone who works with the
Hebrew home propaganda.
The faculty holds regular happy hours,
dances,
and even organized a dating service for
residents.
Gy Date,
g four grandparents.
I like it.
That's great.
Whatever.
No one's getting hurt.
Yeah,
cares.
And they're enjoying themselves.
Fought for our country.
Some of them probably did let him fuck.
This is like an age,
like might have been a few draft dodgers
from Vietnam in that mix.
What about Korea?
But by the way,
by the way,
he needed one of those wars,
but they're really fighting for our
country,
but no,
but they still went.
They still went to Vietnam was a draft.
That was a horrible thing,
but they still went.
They still went.
Well,
it's not their fault.
It was a bullshit war,
it was a bullshit for sure,
but it's not their fault.
Who was the most bullshit war?
The most bullshit war.
What was the most bullshit war?
Because it was literally founded on
bullshit.
Do you know about the Gulf of Tonkin?
I know talking to them a,
you know,
it was a false flag that caught us into
Vietnam has never happened.
This Gulf,
the Gulf of Tonkin incident as it.
I'll take a step further.
I think the threat of communism is
something that we like to do to scare
Americans and the poor Laotians got
caught in the middle of all of this.
I went to Vietnam and they still have.
I'm sorry.
I went to Cambodia and they still have
like active minds because they dropped,
we dropped,
I think more bombs was.
It was several million or something and
it's still an active thing,
like people are still losing body parts
to this.
Sure.
Farmers.
So we're just like,
oops,
a daisy,
sorry.
And they're not an angry people.
I don't know if the threat of communism
was perceived as real because I think if
you look at the rest of the world,
like we were obviously in conflict with
the Soviet Union.
They were worried about China,
the Marxism and Mao and all the various
issues that people have overcome.
I think they were worried that communism
was going to spread.
I think it just one of those things
where once a witch hunt starts like the
mccarthyism area,
that's,
that's really fucking scary.
That shit where they were going after
people and ruining their lives.
They'd went to a meeting.
Sure.
Like if you went to a communist meeting,
I mean we definitely blacklisting
people,
you know,
and it's,
it's a fine line because it's like,
well you're Americans,
you have these rights.
And then like,
who's deciding that line?
I wonder if we're kind of getting into
that now with what we're able to say
online with the whole sexual Predator
thing,
which if you want to talk about draining
a swamp,
like it's great what's happening now,
but then you're going to get guys who
are like,
I never did anything.
It's like,
well,
sorry,
now no one wants to work with you.
Well,
there's people that are absolutely
guilty that are getting caught and then
there's people for sure they're going to
get accused by people who really just
want attention.
You can have that too,
but I think you're going to have way
less.
Okay.
I think you're gonna have less of that
because I think the stakes are so high
that for you to do that,
for you to be the type of person that
accuses someone just for your own
personal gain.
I feel like it's not going to happen as
much just because it's such a serious
thing right now.
It's a serious thing,
but there's so much weirdness to elect
George Sekai.
A guy says he grabbed his dick in 1981.
Hey Dude.
You let it go.
Walk it off.
I'm sorry.
It's also.
It's not as damaging as it is when a man
does it to a young woman.
Percent.
Thank you for saying that.
That's so true.
I've been saying this on stage and I
have a bit.
I don't.
I want to reveal it here,
but I,
there's a big difference between being
threatened for your life,
like if you're dealing with a situation
like,
all right,
this is not the throw Louis ck under the
bus,
but someone was saying like,
what's the big deal?
Someone masturbating in front of you?
This is what I,
this is what I said.
They've never had it happen.
You're a man.
Yup.
Okay.
And if a woman was masturbating in front
of me,
I would not be worried.
Not threatened for your safety.
I would exactly.
That'd be like,
okay,
you want to do that?
But if a man is doing it and they're
blocking the door and it's a man that,
look,
I was in the green room,
not the green room.
The um,
uh,
the bar area,
the comedy store,
you know,
that little narrow pathway.
And this guy walked by,
it was about three months ago and he was
six foot seven,
300 plus pounds.
And He,
when he walked by me,
I just looked at him.
He looked at me.
I got physically nervous,
physically nervous.
Like I was thinking,
okay,
if this guy decided he was going to kill
me,
he was going to smash me.
There's almost nothing I can do about.
He's so much bigger than me.
That is how almost every woman feels
around a large man.
This is the thesis for my last special
for confirmed kills your thesis.
I talk about it.
It's added at length.
How it all goes back to the fact,
all of the suppression,
all of your nervousness as a woman,
all of it goes back to the fact that men
are physically stronger than women in.
My whole joke is if we were stronger,
if women were stronger,
we wouldn't have waited for the right to
vote would have been like,
I'm going to the polls out of the way.
Jeddah diet like it just went.
So it all goes back to that and I think
for some guys it's hard to grasp what
that feels like to feel physically
inferior because it's not mental,
mentally inferior.
It's not someone's funnier.
Your life is threatened when a guy
blocks the door,
when a guys in your weight,
when you're in some guy's home and maybe
he doesn't want to hear it.
No,
he can kill you.
That's all the.
Even a guy that's not that much bigger
than me is still exponentially stronger
than me and that's just the way we're
designed.
It's not every woman is not every man,
but women live with that fear.
So it's so insane.
You know,
they're like,
he jerked off in front of them and at
the time,
you know,
this is a very valid thing.
Like at the time I didn't know what was
happening because your brain isn't
designed to handle like a famous
comedians masturbating in front of me.
I'll file this away.
Well,
not only that,
how about it comes out of the blue.
How about,
how about you process it?
You and I are friends.
We've been friends for a long time.
If we were in some hotel room somewhere
and I said,
can I jerk off in front of you?
You'd be like,
what?
Yeah,
you probably wouldn't eat.
This is not like a rational request.
Like,
Hey,
do you want to get some food?
let's let's go to the bar.
Hey,
there's no neurological path to this.
Where it's like,
yeah,
we'll go to the food bar and get food.
You just opened a door and dropped off a
cliff
and you're just.
You're grabbing onto anything.
So they giggle.
They laugh because that's a natural
reaction.
You're like,
okay,
you can't believe it's happening.
A lot of girls like Ali reisman just
came out,
the gymnast,
her,
the Olympic doctor was molesting her and
another girl as well,
and the guy's already in prison for
child porn,
which is so insane I think at the time,
especially when you're younger.
I have good friends who were like,
I was basically raped or assaulted and
at the time you're laughing and going
along with it because you don't know,
like your brain is like almost shutting
down.
You're like,
I don't know
that it's not okay.
Well,
especially if you're really young,
right?
Sure.
I mean,
you're.
If you're a young kid and you're not
exactly sure you don't have a context
for this action,
right.
So sudden it's happening.
You don't know.
Just don't,
you don't understand,
like I almost got scooped up by a child
molester once when I was really young.
I was like,
I guess it was like eight or nine.
I was in the library and I was looking
at these books and this guy came up to
me and I was looking at.
I was always in a monster books,
like monster movies and this guy came up
to me.
He's like,
you're a monster books.
And I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
I've got some monster books in my car.
You want to see him?
So okay,
got a monster in my pants.
I didn't know any better and know I was
fucking eight years old or whatever.
So I start walking out to his car in the
librarian sees him and me and start
screaming.
She said,
Joseph,
you keep away from that man.
He just got out of jail.
Oh my God.
I was crying and I ran to her and the
guy ran away.
But I think to myself like I had no
idea.
I didn't know what a child molester was.
Sure.
I didn't understand.
You don't know.
And even if he tried to touch you,
you're like,
this feels weird.
I know I don't like this.
It's just such a gray area and our,
our sexuality,
Dr.
Right.
For a doctor to like abuse and you
think,
oh,
maybe he's touching me.
He needs to be doing that.
I don't know what went on.
But your sexuality,
especially as you're younger is so
vulnerable.
Like if you want to fuck up a girl's
life,
all you gotta do is go over and like
grab her boobs as an adult and like
that's it.
Just go up and grab some young kids Dick
or like touch a woman's vagina and
you're fucked.
Like it's such of precious vulnerable
thing.
The fact that any of us get out
unscathed is America.
I had another one when I was 14.
No 13 wasn't in high school yet,
so it was like the year before high
school I used to go fishing at this lake
and there was this old dude that used to
come by the lake.
He was jogging all the time.
Me and my buddies would fish there and
he was a former professor and he Kumbaya
and talked to us.
He was always like really smart and
articulate and interesting to talk to
and it would sit with us while we're
fishing and talk to us.
It was always super friendly and then he
drove up,
drive off or run off.
And then one day I went over his house
and I didn't think anything of it
because I'd been around the sky all the
time.
And He um,
he watched me pee in the bathroom.
Didn't think anything of that either,
like grown man watching me.
P is like normal.
And then like maybe a week later he
showed up at the pond where we would
fish and he was drunk and he told me he
loved me and I remember thinking like,
Oh,
I don't know.
Okay.
I like you too because I'm fishing.
At the time it was like,
what the fuck is this guy going on?
And we're in a weird area of the pond.
There was like no one around.
And it was like a lot of trees and
bushes and shit.
It was,
it was sketchy and our memory said this
to me,
said something about something along the
lines of you can't have love without
sex,
just out of the blue.
Yeah.
That's his opening.
He said he loved me and he said,
you know,
there can't be any love without sex.
I said,
what,
what the fuck?
And I had a knife and I remember I had a
knife and I put my hand in my pocket.
I like a little folding knife and I held
onto it in my pocket and I told him he
had to get away from me and then I'm
leaving and he told me I was
overreacting and I reeled in my line and
got out of there,
but I was like,
this guy wants to do something to me.
I'm,
I can do anything.
I'm like,
maybe I might be able to stab them.
Probably not.
You know,
it's definitely,
I think about that because
especially as a girl,
and I hate to keep saying that,
but it really does.
Like,
it does affect us the most.
And you know,
you get in these,
Uber's like,
you're like,
I'll just get in with this dude,
right?
I'll just get in this cab and hope that
he's not going to snap today.
You know what,
even a cab,
it's a guy's actual car,
right?
So it's even more intimate or just
walking or it's basically your app,
you know,
you have to keep,
you have to be vigilant about it because
like,
if somebody just decides this is what
I'm going to do and we're all vulnerable
to Greece.
Some guy decides to take out an AK 47 or
drive his car into a group.
We're all just sitting ducks,
you know,
and all the preparation in the world,
you can't fight a gun with your fist.
You can't outweigh a man with your body
mass as a woman was a real big girl.
And uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I think about those things.
And so that's why it's tough when you're
walking in,
you're a girl and some guys like smile.
You're like,
I'm just trying to fucking survive.
Forget the smile thing.
That's such a bully move.
Because those guys who do that,
they're only doing that because they're
bigger and stronger than you.
Oh,
and by the way,
smiling causes wrinkles.
Wrinkles.
What if you have done like,
can't even smile.
I don't know about that.
But if you like,
the reason why a guy will do that is
because he can like,
a guy's not going to do that to a bigger
man.
You know what I'm saying?
Like a bigger man walks by,
hey,
smile.
Hey,
fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you're ordering someone to do
something.
But moreover
I'm just trying to.
I'm putting on a face just saying I
don't want to be bothered because I'm
scared and I'm trying to get from point
a to point B and you're praying on that
vulnerability thinking that I want that.
If I want to see your Dick,
I'll tell you,
if I want to talk to you,
I'll look.
Yeah,
you're not thinking that you want that.
What they're doing is they're realizing
that you don't want to have anything to
do with them.
And by saying that they have this power
to affect you,
well,
what scary watch smile wouldn't look
like such a bitch.
Right?
And what's scary is then if you don't,
I don't know what wrath that's going to
incur when I say fuck off,
I better put them on the other side of
the street.
Yeah.
And what's funny,
because I and I talked about it in the
specialist,
I'm not trying to do a bit.
This is such a common conversation.
We have this thing where a guy says
something to him who sweetheart,
and you're like,
fuck off,
and you get tough.
Immediately followed by what if he kills
me?
It's always our thought like,
oh my God,
please don't,
don't follow me.
Oh,
of course.
We came out of this show last night,
this girl's night in show,
and everybody was feeling great.
We walk outside and it's like,
dude walks up,
boat to go to the loader.
You're walking into a group of five
girls having a lively conversation.
You put yourself in the middle and I
walked where I go ill,
I'm not doing that.
And he like started chirping at me.
What's your problem?
Who was a lawyer and my fucking dumb
friends like I think I do sir,
and I'm like,
this is not the time to demonstrate how
compassionate you are.
Fuck,
don't give him a lighter.
Like there's no reason to go anywhere
else.
You're obviously a crazy person,
but that's another incidence.
Where are instance where other,
where a guy will do that because he's
bigger because he can get away with.
That guy's not going to do that to a
group of guys know.
You know what I mean?
That's this.
The reason why he's doing it,
he's doing it because he's as imposing
like he's a big dog walking to a room
in this and sometimes you know,
for shows like I have security
thereafter and it's not,
you know,
not beyond say it's not like people are
throwing themselves at me,
but I found just having a large man,
even if it's a friend of mine standing
next to me,
detours,
even the beginnings of even the inklings
of a let me step to her and see what's
going to happen just for having one
there.
Well,
that's got to be a thing with girls
that's different with like God.
People get obsessed with people.
Guys get obsessed with girls,
girls get obsessed with guys.
There's a lot of people out there that
are unstable and they lock onto someone
that get obsessed with them.
Sure.
But if a man gets obsessed with you
sexually,
that becomes a giant issue
and there is no separation by the way.
You can't just be obsessed with me
because you're like,
oh,
I just,
she was brilliant and I'm totally normal
like relationship with you.
Right.
Had that happen.
I had a stalker.
It was a couple of years ago.
And um,
I did a show in Michigan.
Was it Michigan?
Nope.
I was university of Delaware and I was
going to Michigan the next day.
And,
and the idea of college obviously,
and the woman working there,
she comes up to me,
she goes,
hey,
there's a guy here.
He says,
where's your cousin?
And I was like,
I don't have a cousin in Delaware.
So she leaves,
she comes back,
she goes,
he says he's a comic from La.
And I'm like,
I don't know any comes from Delaware
also.
And then she leaves,
she comes back,
she goes,
he says,
I go,
stop,
stop coming back to me.
This is obviously like several attempts
and now security has to walk me out to
the car.
So we do that.
And so I had it kind of in my mind like
somebody did something.
So I've go to Michigan and I'm in
Michigan,
I'm there for a festival the next day
and the secure.
And I mentioned it.
It just kind of mentioned.
I was like,
this happened yesterday and the security
guard comes over.
And he was like,
yeah,
there was a guy waiting in the hallway
after we cleared it.
And when I talked to him he kind of ran
away and I kind of got his name.
I think he likes his ID for a second.
The guy was like trying to get in,
but he was creepy enough that security
like caught it.
So they showed me the surveillance
tapes,
you see nothing but a grainy face and
like a black leather jacket and what
they thought his name was.
So a couple of weeks later I had,
I was going to play south by southwest,
so I told my manager about it,
so she tells security there,
my buddy,
I'm not gonna,
say his name because he's very shy,
is ex army ranger and works for the
contracts with the government and so I
told him so he called the FBI and they
gave him with just the grainy photo and
what we thought his name was and they
found who he was,
just some nut who of course has guns and
has a record and lives off his family
money somewhere in rural whatever.
And I was at south by southwest and I
had given and I felt bad and this goes
to women feeling bad for taking up
space.
There were way more famous people there
than me.
But here I am.
I can't pick up my badge.
I had to go talk to the police.
Like I had to have an escort everywhere.
I'm doing like a bar show,
you know,
I'm just there to hang out with my
friends and I had to have to all three
shows
and I felt embarrassed because I have
this police escort and like huge movie
stars are there and they don't even have
that and I didn't want anyone to look at
me like who does she think she is?
But I was scared and he had and so it
was the last show and I thought it was
in the clear and I go and I do my set
and one of the cops comes over.
They were like,
he showed up and we caught him,
but had they not been there and they
talked to them and I guess they put the
fear of God in him because they were
like,
she doesn't want to talk to you.
And he goes,
oh,
I don't want to hurt her.
And I'm thinking your version of hurt
and mine are very different.
Like I need my skin.
You probably don't think it hurts to
take it off of me.
How about you don't want to talk to him,
period.
Like he didn't want to hurt her,
but I need to talk to her.
Look,
you never need,
you don't need that.
And it's Texas cops so they love,
they get super hard for you in the
fucking desert and they scared them off
and I've never had to deal with him.
But for months at the Improv at the
customer,
we had this guy's picture up,
Jesus Christ and I did nothing.
You know,
it's just,
you decide like he goes,
she's communicates with me through
meditation and Kabbalah.
I was like,
all right,
let them in Jewish meditation.
No,
I think a Madonna was doing that for
awhile.
Jewish mysticism wasn't madonna like she
was into which all these people that are
like kabbalists that have studied it
forever and she's trying to like hack
it.
She is Madonna.
She gets a velvet rope to the front of
the line.
That was Janet Jackson's tore the velvet
rope tour.
Thought you're making like a pop
reference.
No.
Saying like she gets VIP to the Kabbalah
Center.
Registering in the water.
What is Caballo like w,
what do you know?
Anything about the study of Jewish
mysticism.
So Judaism is actually a very ancient
sort of mystical,
spiritual religion and this Kinda goes
sort of back to its roots and its
something that you can't because I've
always been interested in,
you can't just pick up a book,
like it's a lot of studying,
a lot of like deep seated,
dissecting Hebrew numbers,
you know,
it's not something you just decide
you're going to do,
but I don't know much about it other
than it from ancient Hebrew.
Ancient like it's.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's weird language.
I would love to go.
It's like I love looking at old
languages because you're looking at like
some weird art form and that way it was
the first forms of communication.
Like if you look at it,
you know,
ancient Hebrew or ancient Arabic or
Aramaic or something like that.
Like the,
just the way those things are
structured,
the way the sentence is written out of
this.
Um,
it's several hundred years old,
but it's a Thai Bible.
Ooh.
And it's on my wall,
like I have.
It's written on these,
um,
palm the palm would and flattened it out
and painted it.
So it's like this really like artistic,
weird thing that's framed,
but I just go buy it.
I look at it,
I'm like,
this is like I have no idea what the
fuck it says,
but it's just cool to look at.
Sure.
Weird way of of writing and
communicating these people had was also
fascinating because like they had the
urge that we do to record everything.
People are going to look at ours in a
million years and be like,
why are there all these eggplant emojis?
Why does everything have eggplant and
squirting water?
Why is everyone yellow?
But they had to say,
I always wonder,
did they have.
I mean obviously they didn't have the
same advancements,
but like ancient Greece,
like did they have like what were young
people doing?
Like was it,
what was your fun besides vomiting?
Couldn't vomitorium in wrestling?
Yeah.
Well I would just love to be a fly on
the wall back then.
I mean,
when you're talking about people that
had very little understanding of how the
universe worked or the rudimentary
understanding of science,
just to hear the wisest the wise amongst
them and try to figure out what makes
everything tick.
Talking about how acne is the devil.
We want to talk about how women were
treated.
Then that's what's really weird.
It's like women have always been treated
like shit always.
It's always been some weird sort of
relationship between men and women
because we can get away with it.
That's really the bottom line about at
all.
It's like what's happening today I think
is that because of the ability to
express now,
like it's almost like something could
happen to you in a bad way and no one
could know about it.
Right?
But now everyone can know about it if
you express it.
If you express it,
everyone can know about it.
Everyone can know.
Sure.
And now everybody's realizing that and
there's like a shift where everybody's.
It's like when black lives matter really
came to the forefront,
you know?
And all these white people are like,
oh my God,
I didn't realize America was racist and
black people are like,
really?
Because we did.
So all these women now are like,
yeah,
this shit goes on all the time.
And I even think about in comedy,
you know,
and I went on a twitter rant the other
day about it,
this idea,
it's an art comedy as art and people
feel ownership over it.
So you get these boys clubs,
you know,
I'm very lucky in that I,
like you get like it's a group of dudes
that run the show and they don't like
girls,
whatever it is or the way a lot of guys
make women feel and it's so insane.
I'm like so because you moved to La a
year before me and you and your friends
wrote the same jerk-off jokes.
You somehow think you own this art form
that I've always felt a connection to it
my whole life.
Just because you remember it.
Because I would.
Not only that,
I mean,
I don't mean you get it,
like do you understand it?
But I mean,
does it happen to me as it happened to,
you know,
and the truth is I was able to avoid it
because of what I did in my career early
on because like winning a show like that
makes you,
you get to headline.
So I was never respected.
It's not even that as much as I just was
never in the trenches as much because I
got to headline,
which is always the goal.
Like I just had a different path.
How much,
how much?
How many years were you doing standup
before you?
One last comic standing.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
Right?
So for me,
I'm even more firmly,
I guess planted in my,
in my convictions about sympathizing or
empathizing with women who didn't
have the same advantage and I want to
just,
or anyone being bullied,
but I've see it,
you know,
at clubs that we do.
And these are my home clubs and I love
it.
Coming up the last 10 years I've
watched.
Oh no,
he's a good guy.
And this guy cyst like systematically,
like daily harasses women and all the
guys like,
no,
he's cool.
He's front,
we're friends with him,
you know,
it's like you've seen the.
I've seen that.
I'm not gonna say names,
but there are people who go out of their
way to be horrific and I never see the
guys around us and these are all
contemporaries say anything because it's
like now he's a good guy.
He's our friend and women will dm me.
Female comics will send me messages.
This is happening to me.
He said this to me,
what do I do?
And I'm like,
Oh,
you can do is be kind work on your
jokes.
Fuck that guy doesn't mean anything,
but it is a thing.
Does mean something psychologically.
If you have to go to the club and then
you see that guy and if you see him
right before you have a set.
Oh my God,
yeah.
Oh my God.
I've had,
you know,
disagreements.
I was nervous.
This isn't you.
When I,
when you and I had the,
the thing about your phone number,
I was like,
I don't want to run into Joe.
I'm so afraid of Joe.
And that's someone who's a friend of
mine.
You know,
it's already such a weird thing to go to
work,
but the girls who were like,
oh yeah,
I,
he told me I wasn't funny.
He told me I was a slut.
He told me this,
he told me I was to x,
Y,
Z to this and just as if the guy owns
the art form,
when what breaks my heart is like real
comics,
like you are like Sebastian or like
people that I or Mark Mayer and like
guys that I look up to that I think are
so brilliant,
they don't have time to sit there and
get in the head of some girl who's just
trying to make 15 bucks.
You know,
it's not your emo.
It's only loser.
Well,
I always feel that we're all in the same
boat together and that if you have a
vagina and I have a penis,
it doesn't.
We're all comics.
Like I think the really.
I mean that's got.
It sounds like even to be sincere sounds
like such horseshit and this weird day
and age because you feel like you're
trying to cover up and try.
I'm not those guys.
Hey,
I'm not that Harvey Weinstein Guy.
I'm different.
I'm going to come with me.
Yeah,
I'm a sweetie.
We could sleep on the couch together.
I wouldn't even bother me.
But you know what I mean,
like there's.
But I think it's very important that all
of us that work together,
look,
I could learn shit from comedy,
but from you,
I can learn shit from anybody.
I mean,
I've seen people do do standup.
They've seen me do stand up.
They do it different than me.
We talk.
You've got a different method than I do
there.
There might be something you see,
it's always,
we're all peers and we're pairs,
but you,
I feel like that with friends and I feel
like that with peers in a field like
that.
Within it,
you gotta you gotta be open and if
you're not open you're going to miss
stuff.
You're also very secure and I really do
believe that insecurity,
whether you're a woman hating another
woman,
whether you're a dude trying to like
step to another guy,
it all comes from insecurity.
So when you're run the show with my
buddies or you know,
I've been doing it three years,
I'm old the world,
like you're told that you're,
that you're owed more,
right?
Or concrete job.
I should have more.
It comes from this insecurity of if she
gets something that I deserve and it
comes from this place of you think you
deserve something.
Um,
and that was a big thing for me after I
did the show.
The men that I had to tour with were
horrific,
like mental scars,
indelible marks on my brain,
horrific.
Because there was this entitlement like
how dare she take that,
you know,
how dare you,
when the show,
how dare you not roll over and die.
But so I see that and I don't have to
deal with it as much.
Um,
but I,
my heart breaks because I wish that
these girls five years later could look,
could realize from like a bird's eye
view when it's happening.
I'm like,
that guy's got nothing.
Like if you really are going to be that
mean to a fellow comic,
you obviously hate
yourself so much,
but you don't see that.
Like I wouldn't see that if somebody
hated me,
even if there were a loser.
When someone hates you,
it sucks.
No,
no.
Hate yourself.
Hates them.
Like if you're gonna have someone hates
on you because they saw themselves as
still.
Sorry.
I had a guy when I started I was doing
these like comedy contest and like
Orange County,
which were a total racket,
but I don't even know the guy.
I think he was another comic and he was
like a middle aged dad and he would on a
weekly basis write me hate email calling
me names that I had never been called in
my.
I was like 23 or something.
You were fucking bitch,
like just railing on me and I didn't
like someone jerking off very.
You don't know how to handle that.
No one I've ever even had a woman be
that mean to me.
And so I,
I took it.
I wrote back a couple times like what's
your problem?
And it was just,
he was just a crazy person firing off at
someone and a year later he wrote me an
email to be like,
I'm in Rehab now.
I'm so sorry,
I've got a wife,
I've got kids,
so you enter into this art form and into
the city with the best of intentions,
trying to keep your soul as clean as
possible and you have no control over
the crazy that's going to be in your
path.
You only have control over how you heal
I guess,
and I think every comic is crazy in a
certain way.
There's just no way around it.
If you're funny.
I've never met a single funny one that
wasn't fucking crazy.
They're all crazy.
It's just everyone's crazy as a
different.
Crazy.
Well here's the other side of it.
So you get women and and my whole thing
is like,
you should be fired from your job for
not being funny.
Not because you didn't like fuck
someone.
Right.
But I think some people take it a step
further.
They're like more for women and I'm
like,
no,
no.
Do the jokes be funny.
You shouldn't get the gauges because
you're a girl.
You should get a chance and you should
have a chance to prove yourself.
And not everyone's standing in the way,
but this like more women in comedy.
Right?
The jokes be fucking funny.
I will.
I will fight for you to get that chance,
but I'm not going to hire you
a woman.
The more women in comedy thing is like,
I just want humans to be good at it.
I want good,
funny people and I think there are more
women in comedy now than ever before.
But I think there's more people in
comedy now than ever before.
So saturated.
It's so saturated.
But I think it's a good thing.
There's a lot of.
And there's a lot of support.
Like one of the things that bothers me
the most about any sort of weird shit
that goes on with Comedians,
whether it's boy,
Girl Shit or anything else,
is that there is a comradery that we
share that is very unusual in a fairly
competitive art form.
Competitive in that I don't think it's
as competitive anymore.
And what I mean by this is that I don't
think that the idea of like getting a
sitcom or being the host of the tonight
show or you know,
these,
these limited number of gigs that are
available,
I don't think that's where it's at
anymore.
I think there's more people like you
that are doing netflix specials in me
and we both do podcasts.
Like that kind of thing I think is way
more open to people and it's way easier
for us to all to be supportive of each
other and supportive of each other in
the art form of standup.
Like what's important in our world is
don't steal.
Don't be an asshole to your fellow
comedian.
Support each other and I'm going to be
there for you if you're there.
For me.
I think there's two things to that.
I agree.
I think it's also easier to be
supportive when someone's undeniable.
I think when you're first starting out
and when you're kind of in the clubs and
you're all kind of fighting for to
figure out what you have when someone's
genuinely funny man or a woman,
I'm the first one to be like,
yes,
love that.
Like I visibly fell over subash and when
I bring them on stage and I'm sure he
like,
doesn't love it,
but I'm like,
he's the.
And,
and you are.
I mean,
this sounds like a,
like I'm stroking your ego,
but it's true.
Like you single handedly,
I think change the sort of landscape in
the way that we consume comedy.
Like you have this massive podcast.
You guys don't know.
We're in a studio that is at least 2
million square feet and there aren't
stuffed animals everywhere.
Like what ones were not teddy bears.
And there's elk horns and there's an
interactive dinosaur exhibit.
Like it's huge.
Um,
he's like a monster drink fountain.
It's crazy.
But you know,
having this podcast and then people see
what's possible.
So what's funny is you did this and you
built this sort of podcast empire and
there's other big ones too.
But this is definitely one of the most
consumed on the planet,
so then it sort of opens up this new
avenues and then you get all these other
comics on do podcasts too and not
everybody's equipped to do it and there
is,
I think a glory and being one of the
originals because you kind of paved the
way
and imitators fucked up a lot in the
beginning and got better at it.
And I was having a conversation with a
good buddy of mine this morning about it
and he was asking me about
conversations.
We were just talking about conversations
about letting figure there's like an art
form to letting people talk in a way
that's easy to consume for the people
that are listening.
We are very good listener and I think a
lot of when I started my podcast I did
it so I could work on my listening
skills.
I know you were.
And that was so nice.
Talk about support and you did not have
to do that.
Um,
and I think,
and I don't do a lot of podcasts,
I begged to do yours.
So it's not like you asked me and I was
like,
I'm busy Joe,
but I don't do a lot of them because not
every comic is a good listener or
equipped.
Well,
we were talking about before the show
started about some interviews you've
done,
you know,
and there's,
there's always going to beat it.
It's like you got to want to talk to
people.
I like.
I like talking to people like this is
one of the reasons why podcast is a good
fit for me is because I'm curious.
You're very curious,
very curious.
I like talking to people.
I want to.
Like when I was saying like would I be a
woman for a day?
I want to know how the fuck your brain
works.
I know,
I know you don't know how mine works and
I know I don't know how your works.
I'm fascinated and I think that we try
to figure men and women try to figure
out our interactions with each other
through trial and error and when sexual
harassment and sexual assault and stuff
like this,
what's coming out in the news with
Harvey Weinstein and,
and others.
And even the Kevin Spacey stuff,
what we're starting to see Kevin Spacey
stuff not very applicable to what I'm
talking about because it's men doing it
to men,
but the Harvey Weinstein thing is it's
like here's someone who's not even
trying to think about how women think.
Not only that,
he was trying to think,
how can I,
how can I do this the most?
He had like a network of people helping
him exact that plan.
This wasn't like,
I'm drunk.
Touch my Dick.
This was my assistant's going to score
it.
You Lynn.
I'm going to send spies to try to cover
this up later.
Like it's maniacal.
Did you ever see that article from 1945
with a.
What was that woman's name?
I'll send it to you again.
Jamie Loreano her.
That was like,
if this is Hollywood crazy,
Jamie,
I'm going to send it to you again.
Put this up on the,
on the big screen.
You know,
I got a better version of it where it's
not cutoff.
Hollywood is probably like,
yeah,
goodbye.
Yeah,
this is 1945 til she was complaining
that people were trying to fuck her all
the time and she couldn't get any work
because they said she was cold.
She was like,
in order to get work I have to like
leave my husband,
get rid of my kids and be just fuckable
here.
Does Irish film star Maureen O'hara,
sorry.
Today charge Hollywood producers and
directors of calling her a cold potato
without sex appeal tonight.
Potato refuses to let them make love to
her.
Says the mere in New York correspondent.
Can I read it in her Irish accent?
I'm so upset with us that I'm ready to
quit.
Hollywood marine says it's gotten so
bad.
I hate to come to work in the morning.
I'm helpless.
A helpless victim of a Hollywood
whispering campaign because I don't let
the producer and director kiss me every
morning or tell them or let them,
Paul me and have them spread the words
around town that I'm not a woman,
that I have a cold piece of marble
statuary.
Statuary could word.
I guess Hollywood won't consider me as
anything except a cold hunka marble
until I divorced my husband.
My husband gave me baby away and take my
name and photograph on all the newest
papers.
If that's Hollywood's idea of being a
woman,
I'm ready to quit.
No crazy.
How good my accident is.
Yeah,
it's very good,
but 1945,
but this is what I've always said about
Hollywood and this is one of the real
problems with the people that are
involved in the business,
not just in terms of like the way it's
set up,
but the problems for the person that's
doing it.
That's trying to be an actor,
an actress.
Here's
the problem.
You have to get picked so because you
have to get picked,
you have to go into places like please
like me and you're already fucking
insecure,
which is why you're an actress in the
first place.
The reason why you're an actor in the
first place because you want an
exorbitant amount of attention.
You probably didn't get it when you were
younger.
There's something missing.
People like Daniel Day Lewis or he's a
different cat male.
There's a few of those things out there,
like there's a few of those.
Especially Daniel Day Lewis.
He's been working the last two years is
a cobbler.
Yeah,
fucking shoes.
He's my favorite.
I love that.
He's such a Weirdo.
You know,
and then when you watch him in some
movies,
you know,
like there will be blood and you're
like,
oh,
okay.
This is like you're.
You're not even really acting.
You just become new people.
Yeah.
Like is that he becomes the guy on the
set all the time.
He's the guy all day.
I don't want to spend that much time
outside of my body.
I don't either.
But the problem that I faced when I
first came here was I got,
first of all,
I never wanted to act.
I had zero intention.
I wanted to be a comic,
but then I started getting these
development deals.
I went on to auditions in my very first,
my,
my early days of being an actor.
I got both shows.
That's,
that's.
I got this show called hardball and then
I got news radio.
Those were the two first two auditions
that I ever went on.
I know I didn't,
I just got lucky.
I mean I got his fucking lucky as a
person can get.
Part of it was because I didn't want to
do acting.
I wasn't nervous about it and also I was
coming from fighting.
So was used to like really being
nervous.
Yeah.
So I could go in there like,
Hey,
what's up?
How you guys doing?
I was fine.
I think it's,
there's a kick in the nose.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I'm not going to get a concussion and
bleed out of my ears.
This,
but this environment where you're always
wanting to get picked.
That's why everybody out here is fucking
left wing.
It's not even there.
They're really left lane.
They have to be.
You have to wear a pink pussy hat.
You have to say,
you know all the things that you need to
say.
You're,
you're literally formulating an act and
you bring that act into auditions.
You bring that act onto the red carpet.
That's why you're seeing these people
like Harvey Weinstein who would donate
to the Clinton campaign and do all this.
What seemed to be like very left wing
stuff.
You know,
and he was the darling of left wing,
amy's Miramax,
which is really kind of a progressive
studio.
People will thought me,
wow,
this is just a house of sexual assault.
Allegedly,
you can be a total pervert and have good
politics,
bad politics,
I don't think.
But that's not a pervert,
right?
There's a difference between what he is
in a perfect total psychopath predator.
Um,
and it's interesting too,
because look,
donald trump's a fucking.
He's.
These are the worst.
That being said,
we're going out and we're attacking
people.
There are people like,
I don't speak to my parents.
They voted for trump.
And I'm like,
cool.
Well when they're dead you can,
you can rethink
that.
Those four years,
you know,
and we out actors,
like he's a Republican.
Like,
what are you doing?
Well,
some of them revel in it,
right?
Like James Woods,
he's hilarious.
He's on twitter all day long fighting
with liberals,
but he also was not of the best moral
ground.
Here's something interesting on my book,
there is a Weinstein logo.
A,
my book is the last one to be published
on the back or it's in the,
it's on the spine and what I've been
likening to and I feel like the people
and now it's a shit,
like they got absorbed.
Weinstein books was only two women.
It wasn't like a huge company.
I'd never met him or anything.
I liken it to like when your grandpa
comes back from World War Two and he
brings back like a plate with a Nazi
insignia on it.
Like because they had,
they made their own shit,
like Nazis had like a whole home goods
line.
Um,
and he brings that one thing back.
That's what that book is like.
One of the last ones.
MMM.
With the wwe now they don't have them
anymore.
Well,
look,
before this had happened,
anybody would've done a miramax movie.
He was the guy,
I mean the fucking movies that they put
together.
They put together some of the greatest
movies of all time.
I think it's crazy.
I think we're getting to a place now
where we're realizing,
oh yeah,
for every everything.
There was an upside down every the
upside down world,
there's a whole stranger thing.
There's an underbelly to every.
Every business you can think of,
there is a CD,
horrible side of it with horrible people
and most of us choose to live in the
light and thing.
Things are good.
Every industry has that and we're just
at a place now where like we're kind of
shaking it out and people are coming
forward,
but this has always existed and it's
rampant in every business.
Don't you think?
There's also,
there's like there's systems,
right,
and system systems of power where
someone gets to a position where they
have this massive amount of power almost
like royalty and what a guy like Harvey
Harvey Weinstein was essentially like a
royal in some ways,
right?
Like royalty,
massive power,
right?
Massive money.
Got All of these people terrified of
him.
This big booming figure,
almost like a kingdom would cut your
head off.
Right?
And when you have that kind of power,
it's such an unrealistic position to be
in that.
I think it's human nature to exploit
those unrealistic positions.
That's why this Maureen O'hara articles
fascinating to me because this has
always been the case,
these unrealistic positions where
someone has to get chosen.
There's one person who has a billion
dollars and makes 100 movies a year and
every people have to be chosen to be the
chosen ones to be in those movies.
So you have a whole ecosystem,
right?
And then you have people that are
depending on that ecosystem for their
own survival.
Nobody,
even if they know something wants to say
anything,
it's like,
well,
I didn't know.
Well,
you can't be the first one and then get
fired and then you're fucked.
Right?
That's what they're thinking.
You don't want to be the first one.
That's the other thing.
You don't want to be first,
right?
Because rose McGowan was talking about
this stuff forever and they're like,
whatever.
She's crazy.
Nobody wants,
especially for women.
Nobody wants to listen to that woman.
And historically,
you know,
like Monica Lewinsky,
her life got wrapped and she was a young
woman with the most powerful man in the
world and we love Bill Clinton and she
gets called a whore.
You know,
so it was a paradigm shift where people
are now speaking and in terms of like if
you're talking about exalting one
position and someone getting chosen,
that's shifting to people are like,
fuck it,
I got a cell phone.
I don't need your movie.
I have 8 billion followers on instagram.
You know,
I'll just show my book.
I'll just show my,
but I'll just make a video about me
eating pizza.
I'm relatable now and so everything is
shifting.
Everything shaking out.
I don't think this is ever gonna go away
because if you're the kind of guy that
does that,
that's just something you're going to
think you're wrong.
I think it's going away.
I don't.
I don't see how.
I just don't think you can get away with
it anymore.
Well,
it's for sure going to get watered down.
There's always going to be some amount
of influence.
Powerful people have that are in a
position where they're choosing people,
but you're implying that if you are that
kind of crazy where you're assaulting
women,
that you are choosing good over evil.
You just do.
If you're a predator,
you pray on things,
but he couldn't do that when he was 20
and he didn't have any money and nobody
might've done it a different way.
I think so he might've been.
It's just who he is.
I think sometimes it's who you are.
So this whole I went to rehab.
I'm apologizing,
I'm to,
I'm going to listen.
I'm so sorry.
It's like it's who you are and you can
maybe stop,
but that.
I do believe that that's.
We like to think,
oh,
I'll just go home and reflect for a
little bit.
I love that they have a rehab that they
all go to break for a week.
Give me a break.
We can fix you.
Is it Canyon ranch?
I don't know what it's called.
It's not Kevin Spacey's there right now.
They go for a week,
but I will say,
you know,
absolute power corrupts absolutely.
So Dave becky gave the whole gay,
wrote a follow up letter to Lucy ks,
which I thought was,
it sounded very genuine and there is
something to,
you know,
we have these levels that you exist on,
and you can't be aware.
I feel like I'm going to put my foot in
my mouth,
but you can't be aware of everything
that's going on all the time.
Some people think he was aware of it,
but when you're dealing with these high
level deals and you're at a certain
dollar amount and you're flying high
above everyone else,
you genuinely might not know what's
going on,
but you almost have a responsibility
when you are that powerful and someone
tells you something about your client to
like maybe take it seriously.
If I go on a twitter rant,
my manager calls,
she's was like,
you're acting like a maniac.
Right?
Okay.
But let's,
let's follow that up then.
What,
what does one do?
I don't know.
So if someone is a dave,
becky,
and you think that this woman might be
telling the truth,
and I don't know what Louis said today,
Becky,
but we know that Louis told Mark Marin
ally as mark baron talked about it on
his podcast and he said that he asked
him,
hey man,
are you jerk it off girls?
He said,
no,
I'm not.
It's just a rumor.
It's bullshit.
He goes,
why don't you just talk about this
rumor?
And he goes,
I can't,
you can't do that because then it'll
give it credence.
Which I guess I kind of understand if it
wasn't true,
but I don't think I have an answer.
Yeah,
I don't have one either.
I definitely don't.
I don't want to seem like I'm going one
side or the other.
It's disgusting and it's horrible.
But there's also,
when you hear inklings of rumors,
you hear like little things.
Everybody always says like when their
kid ends up killing a bunch of people
that are like,
I didn't know.
And as the public were like,
how could you not know he exhibited x,
Y,
and Z,
you know,
he did all this.
He had a gun in his room.
He decapitated rabbits.
How could you not know?
Maybe sometimes we are too close to
something and you don't want it to be
true.
Well,
what about that Vegas shooter?
Oh my God.
Like that guy had nothing.
He had no criminal background.
No one had any idea.
He gave his girlfriend $100,000.
She thought he was breaking up with her
and she thought he was giving her money.
Right?
He was just giving her money to get by
and while he was going to murder 50
fucking people are 58 people and kill
himself can apply rationale to an
irrational thing where we don't know.
Well,
any sort of situation like that.
School shooters.
Did you see the um,
most armed man in America piece that
went out?
No.
Can you pull this up?
There's a guy who the most godly man in
Colorado,
his last name is Bernstein.
So as a Jew I was like,
why are we profiling the one Jew that's
a gun nut?
Great.
Uh,
he lives in America.
Most are.
Manny has like $3,000,000
worth of artillery.
You've got to watch this.
He has several shooting ranges.
Shit burning,
but wait,
so his name Bernie is Bernie like
Epstein or something.
It's terrible.
He's got tanks.
He's got blamed for growers.
But first,
yeah,
until I do want to partner.
You go in his house.
Nope.
Oh good.
Three percent of Americans.
According to a recent study,
over 50 percent of guns,
you probably fall into that group.
Why do you think so few people have such
a large concentration of weapons?
You get addicted to them.
You know,
it gets you in your blood,
but driving up my property now and uh,
there's all kinds of warning signs.
As you can see.
If anybody comes on your property and
threatens you with bodily harm,
it's illegal to shoot from Colorado law.
They should have.
Sounds like my dad is.
This is one of the first signs I see.
One guy was a registered democrat.
It says he's got old cars laid out with
dolls,
manikins and bullet holes all over the
car.
The number you want to party with him,
you'll see.
Oh,
do want to party with him?
If,
if you're going to listen,
if we're going to,
not a lot,
just like one night I tell you what
happens at the end or do you want to
watch what happens?
He dies.
No one talks about.
They're like,
so your wife uh,
died.
Oh Jesus,
he killed his wife.
No,
look at this.
He's getting mannequins,
mannequins,
dressed up in women's clothing.
He changes their underwear when it gets
cold outside.
Oh,
Mel.
And this guy is the most heavily armed
men in America.
Legally.
You know,
we've talked about machine guns and hot
rods and Dino stuff highlights,
I don't really care what you like.
So she never says nothing.
Anyway.
I'm real nice to them when it gets cold
in the winter I put underwear.
He's got a New York accent.
Yeah,
he's a Jewish guy from the bronx or
something.
Lives on a ranch in Colorado that's
filled with bullets and guns and
mannequins and he's got his own
firewood.
His wife died and an explosion,
but the way he describes it,
he was like,
we were shooting the show.
I think it was for like a and e and the
last day some they were walking through
smoke and one of the smoke canisters
turn into like a rocket.
It just went through her.
Oh Jeez.
He describes it as if I was describing
what I had for lunch.
He's like,
I went through her and they canceled the
show.
Throw it all away.
Not a tear.
Nothing about the wife.
She's just more like in the show's over.
It's crazy.
Clip.
Whoa.
That guy's probably waiting for someone
to trespass.
Like he's like putting out chocolate and
money,
like on a string and these old too.
So he's got like not much left.
You know.
How much time does he have left but
about his girlfriends.
He's got a girlfriend.
The mannequins mean I can do.
Would you want to meet him and interview
him?
Oh,
how about a show on Netflix called Eliza
interview psychopath.
It's just all comics,
you know,
comics.
She doesn't meet at the store.
Just whoever watches this guy you with
preppers.
It would just be cut back to me.
Just staring at him with my mouth open
with his.
All the soldiers and plastic than other
video on another channel I've found just
loves mannequins.
Oh,
this guy's so creepy.
Maybe doesn't like people.
And this is like how he sort of.
There's a lot of shit.
Look at the size of his fucking house.
This kind of rocket launchers.
This guy's.
Where's he getting the money for?
All this stuff.
Sells guns to.
Oh,
two.
Who?
I don't know.
One by one of his guns.
He can contribute to this.
Uh,
it's too late.
Yeah.
He was like,
in the last couple of weeks we've sold
more guns that we have the whole year.
Well,
here's the thing,
if this guy dies,
whereas all this fucking weaponry going,
I just hope the state swoop in and in
Colorado,
Colorado is the wrong place to pull out
a gun.
Fucking everybody's armed.
Everybody's armed and now everyone's
high.
You're paranoid to things.
He's Got Samurai swords.
Jesus Christ was like this fucking guy.
Interesting character.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people out there like
that in Texas.
Texas is crazy.
I grew up shooting,
not all the time,
but we would go.
My best friend's parents would do these,
I'm sort of not reenactment shootings,
but they would dress up in period
costumes like late 19th century and we
would go out to the country and they
would have these little fake town set up
and it was like timed event shootings
and they all had names like boy named
sue and they had like their cowboy names
and you'd shoot and you'd win like an
antique coin or something,
but they would go and Mr Hewitt had all
the rifles and the guns and shoot at a
was like targets.
Like I remember one was like just the
sort of outline of like a fake saloon
town kind of thing and it's time timed.
You try to get your targets and we would
just drink dr pepper and watched,
but because I didn't and I've shot guns
a couple of times,
it doesn't do much for me so my thing.
But he had a lot of them don't even like
hunting with them.
Do you just.
I feel like you are so masculine that
you see an elk,
you're like time me and you just run
alongside it.
Tackle it by the neck and you just punch
it into submission.
No,
you can't even get close to them.
they can't even know you're there early
Joe.
You can't.
You can't tackle an elk.
Okay,
cool.
We might be able to tackle like a calf.
He's brand new baby.
Cow Elk.
You know.
Do you want to do something crazy?
A baby.
Crazy.
A pony is not a baby horse.
It's not.
Isn't that crazy?
What's a baby horse?
A Colt.
The foal of full.
What's a cult then a horse.
Oh,
Colt is like a full grown horse.
So pony is like a type of horse.
It's its own kind of horse.
Isn't that crazy?
See,
I always thought a pony.
That's right.
I should know that.
I love telling people that fact.
I should know that pony.
Babyhood registers.
You knew it.
What is so a donkey?
What's.
What's the difference in a mule and a
donkey?
One the same as.
No.
One of them is a hybrid.
A DM is a hybrid between a horse.
A donkey is a horse and I'm.
Nope,
a mule,
a mule and a donkey at the same thing.
Well,
one of them is a hybrid and it's
non-viable.
I know that.
Do you mean non-viable?
Meaning hybrid's.
A lot of hybrids can't breed reduced
when you breed a male donkey with a
female horse.
Okay.
That's it.
Notice the mayor.
It's also an ugly type of shoe.
A hiney meanwhile is a mules and ugly
kind of shoe.
For Women.
It's like a slip on.
Put that up.
It looks like enough with the folks who,
by the way,
so many of your fans who like live in
rural areas are like,
I can't believe these people don't know
the difference in the idiots.
It's just ugly fat one,
but.
But if you really hot you can pull that
off.
Guys,
don't give a fuck.
They don't get it.
But like that's a.
that's,
that's a.
That does seem like a satanic sort of a
thing.
Park goat.
No,
it's not even clothing.
The reason why I know this is because we
got mule.
Come for fear factor.
It's cheaper to make people drink meal.
Come [inaudible].
Mule come doesn't really become
anything.
It's just,
it's not good.
How did you say that?
On the show?
Mule emissions sperm.
Oh my God.
We said sperm.
Yeah.
It wasn't my idea.
That's what got the show canceled
though.
I'm one of the few people in show
business that has a show canceled
because we made people drink.
Come.
I think the only one maybe ever.
I feel like there's a lot more than you
think.
Yeah,
there's probably some behind the scenes
stuff off camera.
There's no way.
They drank as much.
Guarantee
that one minute meals on the video on
youtube.
Oh,
Donkey Jews.
Interesting.
Well,
yeah,
that's it.
That's what girls have to go through.
Well,
that was what's interesting.
What they choose between come and urine
yet a drink,
like a vat of urine and a vat of a come
and a lot of the girls chose to come
over the urine because at least we.
It's a similar beast.
You've been there before.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I don't want to watch any day.
Amazing.
I love her running eyeliner.
That's how the show got canceled right
there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
kill you now.
No.
Urine is nothing.
Urine is just like.
You can only drink your own urine.
I think eight times.
I love that she's got.
It's like doing the acid,
doing it more than eight times.
You become insane.
Is that true?
No,
no.
Oh No.
It's a fact about drinking.
You can only drink if you're stranded.
You can only drink your urine a certain
amount of times before it becomes toxic.
Did you read about those two women that
got up?
They got stuck at sea for like five
months with their dog eat the dog.
They had like a year's supply of food on
the boat so that apparently it's falling
apart.
The stories falling apart and now people
don't even believe they were really
stranded as long as they were like.
Apparently people were suspicious right
away because they were too well kept.
Yeah,
so and then now their story would have
been reading and I should shouldn't
really comment on it until I see if he
could find out.
I don't know how much of how much it's
fallen apart because I was reading
something about how it continues to fall
apart.
The story continues with like they
might've just pretended to be at sea for
five months because you would eat that,
that you would eat that dog also,
like you might not if you have a year
supply of food.
Sure.
Okay.
Right.
You can have those like Alex Jones
supplies those fucking buckets at Jim
Baker pushes.
Have you ever seen that at the end time?
Rescued?
Stick with their story.
You would say the same thing.
I did.
Well,
there's an easy way to fact check this
report.
Did you leave like who's the last person
you saw?
I guess they're having some issues.
There's some people that think it's
bullshit.
They claimed daily distress calls were
unanswered and at one point tiger sharks
bumped against the boat.
Might be real.
Well,
you can fact check those distress calls.
See if tiger sharks live in that area.
They do.
Yeah.
That's around Hawaii.
That's where they were.
That's one of the.
One of the real problems with Hawaii is
tiger sharks.
Tiger sharks are one of the most
aggressive of sharks and they get people
all the time.
I think second only to bull sharks.
What does it say indicating that they
had like an emergency beacon that if
they would have activated it would have
alerted this coast guard would have been
found really fast,
but they didn't,
but they for some reason didn't,
didn't know about it necessarily.
There was no storms recorded on
satellite images that have,
I guess supposedly
also what they said caused their
disappearance.
Eliza looks to stick up for girls though
and host that.
I have not read this story.
I'm just looking at,
you know what I was honestly thinking.
No,
I was just like,
of course the two lesbians have like a
giant dog.
I'm assuming one of them is like 46.
One of them is 25,
so I think they're probably lesbians who
knows,
but like that's such a lesbian,
like he's a pit mix,
but we love him.
Yeah.
Because like the big disparity in age,
that's like the difference between like
a guy with a yacht and it's hot
girlfriend.
Who knows?
Maybe she's,
she's her instructor.
You know what I love most about lesbian
couples?
There's almost always like a male and a
female.
Yeah.
Sometimes.
Well,
a lot of the time my best friend and her
wife said,
obviously they're married and so your
best friends,
lesbian,
you were so diverse,
but she,
we've noticed everything.
We are three and so she is,
she was a lesbian when she was three.
She gave us like the quarterback in high
school.
That's probably ruined her.
I think she kind of just figured it out.
I mean he was a psychopath,
but um,
so they're married and they want to have
a baby.
And Michelle,
sorry,
Michelle.
Uh,
you keep her name up.
We're both Jewish,
white.
She's half my body weight.
She's the tiniest and kind of sickly.
She has like plantar fasciitis.
She's got her own issues,
right?
So she wants to carry the baby and her
wife is American,
but Dominican and like strong.
She's like,
but I want to carry the baby.
I'm like,
no,
no.
Our people have like Tay Sachs and,
and uh,
then,
uh,
like just diseases like pass the sec.
It's like a Jewish thing.
It's like a genetic mutation that only
Jewish babies get.
But the point is Jews have to deal with
that.
I'm like,
her people are given birth left and
right and going back to work the same
day.
They don't carry the baby and I'm like
trying to encourage her.
I'm like,
let let the other one do it.
She's like,
no,
I just want to.
I want to go through it because she's
the.
I guess if you had to pick one who's the
boy,
but Michelle wants to do and I'm like,
you're going to get snapped and how
you're going to fit yourself and you're
going to just be a puddle of Jewish skin
and bones.
Let the other one do it.
Are you going to have babies?
I thinking about that,
so I'm getting married in May and then I
was talking to your boyfriend's a very
nice guy,
fiance.
He loves you.
He loves coming to the store.
He's a good dude.
He's a good guy.
And I was just like,
I guess I was like,
we'll get married,
we'll go on a honeymoon.
I was like,
I guess we have those happy when you got
them.
So it was like finally one good one.
This one's going to stick.
I get rid of him,
the Yale story in that one.
That was.
That was so it was like three years ago.
It was quite awhile ago.
That was a great story though when you
brought him around.
I'm like,
well,
I don't want to be too friendly with
them.
You know?
It's like war.
Yeah,
the new guy might get shot,
but then after a couple months it was
like,
hey,
you're still here.
What's up man?
And then we became more and more
friendly.
You're like,
I don't want to be cool to this guy.
She might get rid of them.
Every time I see him a hug him.
He loves you.
He loves seeing it.
Loves watching all the company.
He's a fan of comedy anyway.
Not in a weird way,
but like he listened to your podcast.
I think it's cool for him and he's super
supportive,
but I was like,
I guess we just have a baby.
Like I guess you do that viable.
I don't know.
Many more years.
Got kind of a quick,
I don't know,
checking my stat card.
Did you get an.
I don't have.
I only have one.
Your eggs,
you cook them.
I have one big egg.
One giant one like an ostrich.
I keep it in the back of yourself.
A little gladiator baby.
Like some strong man baby.
I've always wanted that.
Do you think you'll have a boy or a
girl?
Do you have a feeling?
Can I say this?
So I didn't know his job when I was 18
and which is tiny.
That's why your nose is so tiny.
Would you knows you still look like a
little bit of a bump.
It was their worst things didn't shrink
your nostril holes?
No,
I always had small nostril hold down.
So you just got rid of the bump.
The bump.
It's.
I talk about in the book,
it's not like a huge revelation.
I'm Jewish,
like we do this,
but he's half Italian,
half Jewish and he's got a big nose and
I remember looking at it the other day
and I was like,
our kid had better be fucking brilliant
or amazing at sports because if a girl
has a combination of our noses,
it's over for her.
So fingers crossed that she gets someone
else's knows,
maybe by the time you guys decided to
have babies,
crispr will be totally dialed in,
get a nice little Christie Brinkley
knows.
I don't know,
maybe we'll have.
It'll be an APP at that point.
Or if it's a dude,
a big nose just gives you like
character.
Big Nose for dude is fine and I'm
praying because he's very tall.
If it's a girl,
maybe she's just a brilliant athlete and
then it's like,
who cares?
Right.
But it's probably not gonna happen.
Probably just be kind of funny.
And who knows,
who knows.
That's the interesting thing about
having children that I've found is that
they come out of the box,
their own little mind,
their own little personality.
You just kind of nurture that
personality along the way.
But you know,
my two youngest daughters could not be
different.
They're so similar to each other.
They're there so dissimilar rather to
each other.
Yeah.
That happens.
My brother and I are,
I don't know where he's from,
the planet Zap Guitar and we just,
uh,
I don't know,
it's just the way it would just be.
It's a weird combination of like we're
talking about nurture and nature and do
you,
but see the thing is about a woman
having a baby go on.
Is that you,
especially as a comic,
it would be much more difficult for you
to do the road?
I think.
I think,
I don't know anything about it.
I don't know,
you know,
I know that I work out a lot and so
obviously the more mobile and healthy
you are,
it's easier,
you know,
there's a couple of months where you
can't,
but there's also a couple of months of
the year where I don't do the road
anyway.
Like I think I could tailor the schedule
around it and we certainly could because
you're successful because you make
enough money to hire help and hire
people to help you when you travel.
Oh my God,
absolutely.
I don't know.
But your whole life changed.
I think about that a lot.
Uh,
you know,
it's at night,
it's 10:00.
I'm like,
let's go grab dinner.
Don't do that,
do that.
So I don't know,
I guess that's like the next step,
but you just adjust.
Your life becomes so much,
it becomes very strange,
like hanging out with your own kids is.
It's,
it's very odd because the love that you
feel for them is so intense and so
weird.
Yeah.
It's like this warm,
cuddly love,
but it's also like while you're doing
it,
you're,
you're cuddling with your kid,
you know,
talking with them and while you're
talking with them,
for me at least,
I'm like,
I can't even believe you're real.
You can't even believe this is a
daughter.
Like I have a daughter for forever.
Yeah.
And we're talking and she's like,
well,
what do you think about that?
I'm like,
no,
what do you think about that?
And we're having a little calmer.
You're worried that they're thinking at
all.
You're like,
you were just a puddle of mush.
So I don't know,
but I'm open to.
I think a big problem in our society is
that we expect women,
like you've got to have this career,
have this body,
have this family,
but why do we do that?
We do that because it's always been that
way.
Who is we in this group?
Right?
But how many people do that?
How many people do expect you to have
all these things?
I think it's a projection,
but obviously when you get down to it,
nobody cares what you actually do.
But it's what's put out there as what
looks like happiness and I even talk
about this because I never,
I'm not trying to pretend like what I'm
saying is something I'm thinking about
right now.
I've thought about it.
I wrote about it.
It,
you do have to do this digging to be
like,
what does my happiness actually look
like?
And it might not be the cookie cutter
image that is kind of put on all of us.
Like I have a very weird job,
but if I couldn't do this job I would,
I would be the saddest person.
Like standup comedy gives me the most
joy and uh,
that is a huge.
I'm in a relationship with that and I
have to factor everything sort of around
it.
Yeah.
Until I have a kid.
And then who knows?
You don't have one.
It does change.
I mean,
I hate to say Louis C,
k game.
He created place once came to having a
kid,
which is very odd.
What he said.
Let it change you and I don't know Louis
very well.
I should say this too because people,
somebody,
somebody was giving me a hard time about
not commenting on it.
No.
My,
my thought was like,
first of all I want to gather my
thoughts.
Absolutely.
And second of all,
I don't know him that well.
I don't even have his phone number.
I've never had a phone call
conversations with him.
I bet we've exchanged emails maybe three
times ever and he and I have run into
each other at clubs and said hi,
we've never gone out and hung out
together.
I'm not good friends with them.
So when all this was going down,
it's not like I had information.
Like if Joey Diaz did something fucked
up and people wanted me to comment,
first of all,
I would never say anything bad no matter
what joy diaz did.
Sorry.
That's just the way it is.
If there's just no way around.
Yeah.
If you knew he raped someone,
this is horrible.
Alright,
so sorry that he did that,
but when,
you know,
I mean I,
I would never,
I would never throw them under the bus,
you know what I'm saying?
There's bus throwing and then there's
bus throwing,
there's a comment after sort of
condemning,
condemning it and then there was of
course like there was a guy who was in
that movie baby driver,
um,
and he asked us,
no,
it was like at the 48th lead or
something and he went on some show and
just went off about Kevin and so
everyone's like,
it was like,
it looked like a way to get attention.
Like yeah,
when I was on set he didn't seem that
cool and it was so much in retrospect,
but he's not the guy that's on the
walking dead,
the punisher guy.
I don't know,
isn't that him?
I just saw that.
Yeah,
I think it's that guy who's pretty
successful.
He's,
he's the new punisher in that Netflix
just seemed very like bandwagon jumping.
When the Louis C K thing happened.
I can speak from a perspective of a
woman who's seen this kind of stuff.
I don't know.
I brought him up twice at the store.
That's my knowledge of him.
But you get these emails from like the
New York Times or like,
Hey,
if you have anything you want to say or
if you know any other things,
I'm like,
I don't and I don't want to attach
myself.
I don't want to be like,
I didn't want to be part of that story
just for the sake of it.
Because then you look like a fame whore.
Well that's also the problem.
Like you get caught up in something
where you become inexorably connected to
this awful event and you didn't do
anything.
Sure.
Yeah.
So Joey didn't do anything.
It was just like,
not joey,
Joey,
but oddly enough,
it's crazy as joey is,
he's a very gentle person.
He's a giant.
He's Puerto Rican.
He's Cuban.
Sorry.
Giant Cuban teddy bear.
He is because he seems so tough and he
loves St Cox Soccer,
but he is just,
he's like,
he's just so kind and he's got these
eyes like a whale,
like they're just ancient and big,
like the camel eyelashes.
He's got these lovely I and you and he
smiles at you like a toddler.
I love him.
He's the best.
I exchanged emails with him maybe once
every three or four years.
We've texted each other maybe 10 times
ever for all only phone calls.
Calls me every couple of days.
What's up cock sucker.
What are you doing,
brother?
What's going on?
Is He wants to talk to you.
Joey wants to talk to you.
If I ever ever text him is because I
have to send an address to him.
You know,
he's got to like put it in his
navigation system.
That's it.
He,
he calls you.
He lovely.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a beautiful person and you know,
he,
he and I were talking about this whole
Louis,
c,
k thing and he was like,
you know,
he goes,
you know what's fucking crazy?
He was like,
I held somebody at gunpoint.
He goes,
he goes,
fuck fucking kidnapping.
And everybody's like,
ah,
you were crazy.
But it goes like,
this is the kind of thing.
This is the kind of thing that sticks
because he did it to one of us.
Right?
Like if you in our world like we are all
the same,
we're all the same thing.
I mean there's gonna be some weird
pettiness and bullshit and there's gonna
be some prejudices and it's going to be
some individuals that are supportive,
but overall amongst the good eggs
amongst the ones that you and I
associate with,
we are all.
We all consider each other same thing.
Good.
We are,
we understand each other's hearts and we
know how hard it is and what it's like.
And we all know that it's us.
Even though the audiences are friends,
it's US versus them.
It's the club versus you know,
you're trying to do a job and we know
exactly what this very weird job entails
and we know the way the other person
thinks like we have fucked up thoughts
and it's okay to admit these thoughts to
each other and it's a very special bond
and you can't just be like,
I'm a comic.
I get it.
Like you have to kind of earn it and
there's a respect there.
And so it's what he did as deplorable
and it was with other comics and I feel
bad because I feel bad because everybody
gets so angry at women,
they're like,
why now?
And I'm like,
because there's safety in numbers and no
one would listen before.
But people knew,
they knew.
Some people knew.
They knew to a degree.
Like I knew I knew the girls names,
but I didn't know if it was true.
It was a rumor you don't know and you
don't want to be the one that's running
out there like with a lit torch and
you're wrong.
It's going to sound fucked up,
but I'm going to take a chance with it
anyway.
You Ready?
Have you put yourself?
Like I put myself in Harvey Weinstein's
brain.
Not Really,
but I sat down and I tried to think
like,
what,
what would this guy like?
How would his brain work?
Because he just like,
like lost in the throes of the addiction
of power and sex in this chase of
getting all these superstars to suck his
dick.
Which is apparently what a lot of them
did.
I mean I've talked to women that know
people in the business and it was like
negotiating tactic,
like yeah,
he would give them roles if they did and
he always followed up.
He always honored his word was wondering
about that.
Yeah.
I was wondering like how do you ensure
someone gives you the part?
I don't know.
I mean he had a reputation for doing it,
you know,
the,
the contract thing that he had you,
his contract with,
with Miramax,
with the Weinstein group.
Oh,
it was like a sexual harassment.
Like a clause.
Yeah,
covering up too.
But they had it like in tears,
like one would be worth two fifths
because they knew it was fucking crazy.
They knew.
I mean that is.
If that's not complicit then what is.
But have you done,
have you tried to put yourself in the
Louis Ck is brain?
Yes and no because I definitely have had
this thought.
I think when you get to a certain level,
and I see there's,
this wasn't at that level then this is
the thing.
We did a poll and it was a long time
ago.
Let me find,
forget the level I've found with a lot
of male comics.
There is a certain like a lot of
perverts,
whatever.
There's a certain set of blinders,
like I can do whatever I want.
There's almost like a lack of
accountability.
You show up drunk or high or fucked up
and they're like,
oh,
he's so creative.
It's a certain allowance we give to men
and then people when they get famous,
you can do whatever you want.
I,
I pride myself.
I'm always on time.
I don't show up anywhere drunk like I
just take it a little bit more seriously
because I know I have to work a little
bit harder whether being a girl helps or
not at times.
It just depends on the day.
I do think that there's a lack of
awareness about other people and I do
think at a certain level there is a
mindset of like,
because I've seen this in lower tiered
comics,
she doesn't matter what I say to you
when I call you a bitch or a piece of
shit or I harass you,
you don't matter because you're not
gonna make it.
You're not going to make it.
You don't matter.
And I do.
I've seen this.
I'm not going to go into names.
I've heard things that other women will
confide in me that men say to them.
I remember starting at the store,
things that were said to me by men who
probably don't remember.
They said it cause there's like a
cavalier.
Just I'll just say fucking whatever I
hurt.
I want her to hurt.
Fuck you.
You're a bitch.
You're body's discussing.
You don't matter.
Your body is disgusting.
That's the.
That's the weird one,
right?
Like I hurt.
So I want her to hurt.
There's a comic at the store.
All the guys are friends with all of
them.
Me,
I don't know.
Maybe he's not there a ton anymore.
It was definitely.
He was definitely like a fixture there
in the early years when I was there,
I,
we were at another comic's house for a
party.
I was standing there and he walked up to
me.
I hadn't said a word.
He said something rude to a girlfriend
of mine because he was hitting on her
and that didn't go well and he just
looked at me and he went,
you better keep working out because your
body's not going to be like that
forever.
And I was like,
hi.
And the only other thing he ever said to
me was like 10 years later he yelled at
me because I brought my dog to the
store,
but it was body does look like though
forever,
but also like stupid things stupid and
it's so.
It's meant to for me to be like,
why did you say that we should go fuck,
that will help.
And it did not have.
Does that work?
It must work on the most deprived girls
and he just picked the wrong one,
but it of course,
but that doesn't.
Does that work on the girls with the
lowest self esteem?
Does that ever work?
It must.
Or they might think it works or are you
engaging?
Then it turns out,
oh,
he's a nice guy.
I don't know,
maybe it's like one of those,
hey,
you should smile.
Look,
it never works,
but it's been nice.
I think it's more of like,
I don't know how to talk.
So you start with that and then the
girls like,
I was smiling and he's like,
oh cool.
And it's just like an opening for
someone who's not as articulate,
awkward opening from.
I was,
I'm not going to say the state,
so we'll just say it was California,
but it wasn't.
I was,
I was headlining a club.
Um,
so as years and years and years ago,
because the club is not that great.
And there was a guy who was opening for
me and it's weird.
My power dynamic is different because
I'm the headliner,
I've never told a guy he has to like
sleep with me to get a gig or something
like that.
And I went,
oh my,
just like licking my purse and left and
right.
My box,
I'm okay.
I did it once.
Okay.
So he was the opener and he was like,
oh,
can I show you around?
Which as the opener behooves you like to
be nice to the headliner.
Like if I like you,
I have plenty of friends that I just
take with me because they were cool.
Um,
so we like hung out.
We got,
we just say,
show me around his shitty city.
And then on that Saturday night I had a
friend in town,
it was like a guy and I left with them.
We all went to a bar and I left with the
guy that I was friends with and this
comic lost his shit.
Started sending me texts,
like,
how could you,
I spent all this time with you,
do you know who I am?
Like just losing it.
And I'm like,
and I left.
I was out of the city,
I was going somewhere else and he's
harassing me and I contacted a friend of
ours was a mutual friend and I was like,
you better check your boy.
Like,
what is his problem?
He's like,
no,
he's a good guy.
He's my friend,
like,
did nothing to defend me and this guy's
just like spewing this vitriolic
garbage.
Actually I think sober,
but you could be right.
I don't know.
And the other day I was at the Improv
and this piece of shit was the host and
I was like closing the show out and I
hadn't seen him in years and I wasn't
about to give him the satisfaction or
anything and I go on and he bought,
he died a thousand deaths and I was just
sitting there watching and I know that
he knew that I was there and he knew
what he had done.
So they felt like shit.
I felt like shit.
And then he was onstage.
I'm not,
I can't tell the restaurant that I know
no matter,
but he left his phone on stage and I
made him come back up and get it.
I was like,
Hey,
he was calling himself like he had like
a cool nickname for himself.
I called him back and he had to like,
come get his phone and then I fucking
wrecked it.
But it was more like,
you thought I was nobody you thought you
could treat me like that.
But why did he think that if he was the
opening act,
because he probably thought I didn't
deserve it or he's a crazy person or
because I was in his city,
but I'd never seen behavior like that
exhibited by someone who was opening for
me.
But it was just like
male female shit that's like he was
courting you.
He thought that he got mad that I left
with someone else.
He thought that you and him were hanging
out and that you liked him and it was
eventually going to lead to him banging
the chicken.
One last comic standing.
I just want to be
before ever had right after it.
Yeah.
No,
I would have been after a and I'm sure
that if you were heading,
it was after for sure,
but I'm sure that girls like I've heard,
you know,
male friends of mine,
like you,
I fuck all my openers,
you know like guys do that.
I've never had the luxury.
Sounds like a bad practice.
Seems like a super gross practice.
But I think a lot of guys do.
It just doesn't seem smart.
I always tell guys to not.
Well,
I should never say don't fuck other
comedians because like Tom Seger and
Christina [inaudible],
they're great.
That worked out.
That worked out like Moshe Kasher,
Natasha Leggiero that worked out.
I think it either works out splendidly
or is a nightmare.
Right?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Well,
one thing would be that the person would
understand what you do because very few
people do.
I think,
and I would think as a girl,
it's got to be hard when you're the
funny one,
like if you're the funny one and you're
dating a guy and maybe they.
Well you're see,
that's the thing is your fiance is so
chill.
Like
he's so funny too,
but he doesn't need.
He doesn't need any attention.
That's the,
that's the dynamic.
There is one of,
you know,
and I don't really seek it out outside
of Sannup I'm not.
When you get it all out.
Yeah.
Get it out of your system and I don't
want to be greedy about it and sometimes
you don't know,
you know,
you don't know.
You start dating someone,
then you realize,
oh,
they can't handle this other gels,
but it takes a minute.
And with comics it's interesting.
You rarely see a super successful female
comic with like a guy that's like
middling at the chuckle bucket.
Never,
never.
Can you think of one?
I don't know any of them.
I don't know any like headliners that
fuck their opening acts that are girls
now and I mean maybe they do.
Maybe it's cool if they do a cool.
That's cool.
I think that fence.
Yeah,
let them know.
Flip the script.
Yeah.
Like just get back to the business of
comedy.
What was it like headlining after three
years because I did a little bit of
that,
but I had um,
I had a manager who was like a really
good.
When I got my manager when I was about
three years in and I headlined a bunch
of places where I really did not deserve
what.
He got me a bunch of gigs and I.
But I didn't have any pressure on me the
way you did winning last comic standing.
I was just sort of just starting out.
So you go on this tour right after the
last comic standing I think,
Oh my God,
I could've been doing that much time
because there was like four of us.
So I just close it out.
Um,
how much time you think you're doing?
I want to say 15,
20,
you know?
And so you finished that and it's
interesting because you,
when something like that and it's like,
okay,
figure it out now.
Right.
Sink or swim.
And some people sang,
some people swim after winning that
show.
Most.
Sorry.
Most sank.
And I,
that being said,
you get some of these guys already had
careers like John have fron was alonzo
boat and like they're good and they were
fine and they do fine as both those
guys.
I just kind of scraped together what you
have.
Even on the tour,
I don't know if I was always the best
one of the night,
but people are still there to see you or
their favorite one.
So you're just coming from this sort of
scared.
But also you have confidence but also
humble place of like,
I hope that I can stretch this.
It's enough.
And so you have about 45 minutes,
at least I did when you were done,
when a,
when you're ready to headline.
And I think that's a lot of the energy
that I put toward it was like,
I'm just going to talk really,
really fast that way if you don't laugh,
doesn't matter.
You don't know you didn't like because I
got another joke right here and that has
sort of become a style for now.
Now it's not about a fear,
it's more of I'm so excited to talk.
We did.
Me and some other comics did this Ray
Romano charity event a couple of weeks
ago and Mark Marin was on it with me and
we went downstairs to watch ray to Kinda
hear what the crowd sounded like.
And so he was doing well and mark turns
to me,
this is the funniest thing ever.
And he goes,
they're fine.
I go,
yeah,
they're good.
He goes,
you'll be fine.
I go,
yeah.
He goes,
just do what you always do.
Steam roll over the crowd.
Don't wait for applause,
dear voices and get off stage.
And I almost cried from laughing because
it was like no one ever breaks my balls
like that.
And it's true.
I do that.
And that's from that competitive
situation,
like that sort of energy.
Well you have the hard hard ass exterior
so I don't think a lot of people take a
chance on breaking your balls,
which is a shame because I think it's
like the best way to show that you love
someone and it's the best way to know
that somebody loves you is if they do
that,
you can tell the intention that shield
also keeps you from getting harassed by
creeps to.
They don't believe they can get away
with it maybe.
And that's fine.
I think so for sure.
Right.
I mean,
I'm sure you've been harassed,
but I think if you were more vulnerable,
you've probably been harassed more.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I mean you try not to give people a
chance.
You know,
you're at a meet and greet after you're
seeing your fans.
And especially after I was talking about
with other comics.
But yeah,
after for sure.
Oh,
with other comics,
I think with other comics,
I know you win the show three years in
and then you're at a certain level of
kind of a level.
All by myself,
I didn't have a lot of other women I
related to because no one else was out
there that I didn't know any other women
you're kinda lonely out there.
Um,
and so I would look up to people like
you and I consider myself a colleague of
yours now,
but at the time I was just like,
what,
how do I,
you're so much higher than me,
you know?
Um,
and I didn't know you.
I didn't know any of these guys.
So it's just,
I dunno,
I don't think any of the comics would
step to me because they were,
you not around comics a lot.
I don't remember when we met.
I think I knew we knew each other.
Like it took time.
I was always at the store,
but I mean I think it was just,
I think you were around though in the
days that I wasn't at the store level.
What year did you win last comic
standing?
Two thousand eight.
Yeah.
See I wasn't there then.
Yeah,
you weren't there,
but obviously everyone knew who you
were.
It's weird.
I was talking to Steve Simone about
this.
There are people,
you know your whole career,
but you may not start talking to them
until recently and then it's as if you
were always friends.
So now I consider myself like an
upperclassman there.
I'm also,
I really tried to just be kind to the
other comics door guys,
younger comics I've always given and
you're like this too.
It gives someone the time of day if
you're going to be respectful and nice.
I have no problem giving it back.
You know a lot of those door guys,
like guys who started out as door guys,
Duncan and Ra are two of my best
friends.
They were both door guys.
It's a lot of people started as door
guys.
Jessica Wellington was the only girl and
I have her come feature for me.
She did my show last night.
That's the kind of girl that needs a
chance because she is like in a boy's
club within a boys club because I work
with men.
She's a door guy,
she's a girl,
so it's all dudes and she's at a store
at the store.
Um,
and I was like,
someone needs to be nice to this girl,
a fucking shitty job.
It's tough,
but you're around comedy all the time.
I mean,
you're,
you're at the world series of comedy on
a daily basis.
I mean,
imagine you're a cover booth person,
you get a chance to sit there and watch
some of the best shows.
Holy Shit,
Dave Chappelle
just showed up.
Holy Fuck.
And you're sitting there from that cover
booth watching Dave Chappelle and he
brings most def on stage with them or
something like that.
That shit happens there all the time.
Oh my God.
He's bringing up Chris Rock.
Your fucking head's ready to explode.
And I mean there's a,
there's a reality of work in there that
doesn't exist anywhere else to go over
the laugh factory,
you know,
you ain't getting that fucking reality.
Ucla standup comic showcase night.
Cool.
That place can burn.
I get very protective.
I told you what you know,
you know why I say that,
right?
You know about this right now.
There's a bunch of Shit I could tell you
things to van.
From there I am banned from the laugh
factory,
a club that I've been a regular at
forever.
I've told you the story.
I won't repeat it if I told them to you.
Boy,
you told it to me,
but it's fine.
I started going there under the idea
that I should support the club because I
don't want it to go under and then I
don't want it to go under it.
That's so sad.
Why I found out they record all your
sets.
Uh,
I will say that I get,
you know,
the store is.
I always say that the comedy store,
the or in particular is like an abusive
boyfriend.
Like you're like,
this hurts.
Oh my God.
And then when you don't go for a while,
you're like,
I need you.
I need.
It's like Stockholm Syndrome training.
It's like doing a set with a giant
weight vest on.
It's like swinging two bats
times.
It's great if you can,
if you can compete or hang rather in
that environment you can go anywhere
else you'd be killing.
It's so true.
And you know,
you get comics that kind of get the vibe
of the store from a couple of years ago
when it wasn't the friendliest place and
it has that reputation.
But I take great solace in knowing that
like my home is an intimidating
environment and I love whatever space
I've carved out there and I don't take
it for granted and I try to respect the
shows and respect the audience and you
know,
I'm so proud to be a store comic.
It's not the kindness of lovers all the
time.
It's not always the most supportive,
but I'm very proud of that upbringing
because that's,
that storm made me the comic that I am,
that our,
you know,
um,
the main room where it's all Swedish
tourist and you're like,
he does not want me to talk and it just
makes you so you can go anywhere in
comic shit on it.
And I'm like,
you just sound jealous because you can't
hang shits on the stove all the time.
I didn't say that.
It's just a regular comics you did.
It's just they don't like it.
It's because they don't like bombing.
But anybody who makes fun of something
that you're afraid of.
Yeah.
Well then there's things to make fun of
just because they saw bombing there
feels so good though.
Like it's like pushing into a bruise.
You're like,
yes,
I need this.
Oh,
interesting.
Well you've got a good attitude about
it.
I still did the Improv.
I'm doing the improv tonight.
Yeah.
And is cool.
The store's got it.
So there's something about it though.
Yeah,
there's a grittiness to it.
I'm very proud of it.
And the Improv's never been anything but
lovely to me.
It was the first club I got past that.
It's still great club and the Comedy
Union.
Fucking stupid piano off the stage.
Oh my God.
And they see behind
it,
behind the fucking pain.
I apologize to those people.
Every time I'm like,
I someone send them a drink because you
can only see my feet and what have you
have to do something physical and you're
doing it behind the piano.
So for the one time Owen Benjamin drops
in.
We have a whole piano.
Exactly.
That's what I told Owen.
I said,
you need to bring your own fucking
piano.
You and Craig Robinson bring a keyboard,
asshole.
What the fuck?
It's just like one of those old school
things that nobody ever got rid of.
I think.
I mean,
there's a lot of things to talk to them
into it.
You think that was luck?
That would change the world.
What do to send the email to make the
club way better?
I know people.
I got some email addresses I could send
you love talking about this offline.
We're going to talk about a bunch of
things offline.
I will.
I need to remember all the different
people that said fucked up things to you
that you don't want to say.
Have a name on the tip of my tongue.
I'm going to say it the second way.
Turn it off.
I can't wait.
Let's wrap it up now.
So your book,
let's we can wrap it up now.
I'm a [inaudible] girl.
Logic avail.
Available right now.
Probably the last Harvey Weinstein
approved book ever.
Yeah,
right.
I wrote you something on this.
You.
Yeah.
I won't read it though.
It's very small.
I don't want to be A.
I don't want to tear up.
Please buy my book to go buy her book.
You fucks and go see her on tour.
She's very funny.
And where are you at?
Where can people get your tour dates and
nonstop.
So go to [inaudible] dot com and we just
announced my fourth netflix special is
going to be on the USS Hornet off the
coast of San Francisco.
In the bay.
You're going to stand up special on a
boat on a aircraft carrier.
Holy Shit.
Well you announced it today.
That's bad ass.
Have you ever done it before?
Have you ever performed on an aircraft
carrier?
I did on the SS dentists in the Persian
Gulf on a Uso tour.
So Holy Shit,
I stole the idea.
That's a great idea to do a special
there.
Whoa.
You're going to wear the red,
white and Blue Bikini.
I think I might just wear a white body
suit or a cammo bodysuit cam.
Oh No,
I'm talking like that.
I liked that.
I like that.
Alright,
thank you Eliza.
Thanks.
We'll see you tomorrow.
You fucks.